THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CURVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WHILE CONDUCTING TO
KEEP YOU KNOW WHAT TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF BOTH
THE PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON A COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND NOW
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ZERO FOUR
ONE SIX SEVEN FOUR. WE MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR ON
THAT IF I YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY DRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND DEVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. GIVEN THE TIME LIMIT
ON THE VEIL ABILITY THIS
HEARING ROOM TODAY THE CHAIR
MAY IMPOSE A TIME CAP ON PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR BILLS HEARD. IF
YOU AREN'T ABLE TO VERBALLY
EXPRESS YOUR POSITION ON A BILL
DURING THIS HEARING. YOU MAY
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. AND
SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES IS WE
PROCEED TODAY. I WOULD
APPRECIATE IF WE COULD PLEASE
ALL BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES.
CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE TEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA THERE ARE
THREE AGENDA ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY. THOSE
ARE ITEMS NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT
OH THREE BY CENTER BELL. I AND
NUMBER SEVEN SB TEN TWENTY NINE
BY CENTER PAN. AND ITEM TEN SB
TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
NIELSEN. BEFORE WE BEGIN
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS- THIS
LAST THAT WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HERE NIELSEN GONZALES GROVE
HER DAUGHTER NOW. LEYVA
MITCHELL MON EIGHTEEN YEAR
RUBIO. QUIRK. THANK YOU A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND YOU CLAIM
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH SIDE OF THE ONLY ADMITTED
PERMITTED A TOTAL THREE MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY RATHER NOT
CUSTOMARY SIX. THAT ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND A POSITION ON
THE MEASURES AS HAS BEEN
CUSTOMARY. SO OUR FIRST ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY IS SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE BY SENAOR HILL
AND OUR FIRST AUTHOR CENTER
HILL WELCOME. AND PLEASE
PRESENT SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
THIS MORNING. UNDER THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS ALONE E. CIGARETTE USE
AMONG PEOPLE INCREASED BY ONE
HUNDRED AND 35% IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS ALONE E. CIGARETTE USE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE INCREASED BY
ONE HUNDRED AND 35% THERE ARE
NOW FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
YOUNG AMERICANS. WHO USE E.
CIGARETTES REGULARLY THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED SURGE IN YOUTH
NICOTINE CONSUMPTION AND HAS
BEEN DONE DECADES DECADES OF
DECLINES OF YOUTH TOBACCO USE
THE E. CIGARETTE INDUSTRY
COPIED FROM THE BIG TOBACCO
PLAYBOOK LAUREN YOUNG AND OUR
KIDS WITH PERVASIVE MARKETING
FALSE PROMISES AND KID FRIENDLY
FLAVORS. COMPANIES LIKE JUL
ABSOLVE THEMSELVES FROM
RESPONSIBILITY BY DOWNPLAYING
HOW ADDICTIVE AND DANGEROUS
THEIR PRODUCTS ARE THE NICOTINE
IN ONE JUL POT IS EQUIVALENT TO
TWENTY CIGARETTES. JUL USED YOU
FORMAT MODELS SLOGANS LIKE
QUOTE GET INTO THE TROPICAL
MOOD OF SUMMER WITH MANGO JEWEL
POT. AND EVEN MARKETED TO KIDS
ON SHOOL CAMPUSES. WALL TOOL
IS THE MOST POPULAR E.
CIGARETTE COMPANY THEY ARE
HARDLY THE ONE THAT USES THESE
TAX THE ONLY ONE THAT USES
THESE TACTICS. FLAVORS LIKE
BUBBLE GUM LEMON DROP IN FRUIT
LOOPS ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE AND
PERVASIVELY MARKET. IT IS
IMPORTANT UNDERSCORE THE
EXPLOSION OF FLAVORED NICOTINE
PRODUCTS IN THE ROLE THEY PLAY
BOTH IN THIS EPIDEMIC. AND IN
THE DICK DEAN NEW USERS WILL
BIG TOBACCO ARGUES FLAVORS LIKE.
A CRUNCHY CATER TO ADULT TASTES%
COMMONSENSE AND DATA. TELL US
OTHERWISE FLAVORS PLAY AN
OUTSIZED AND DANGEROUS ROLE IN
USED TOBACCO INITIATION. WITH
80% OF YOUTH THAT HAVE USED
TOBACCO STARTED WITH A FLAVORED
PRODUCT AND AT LEAST REPEAT
THAT. EIGHTY PERCENT. OF YOUTH
WHO START SMOKING START WITH A
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS. THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF TEEN
SMOKERS REPORT USING FLAVOR
PRODUCTS. N. FLAVORED TOBACCO
USE IS ACTUALLY HIGHER AMONG
YOUTH THAN ADULTS MENTHOL
CIGARETTES SWEETS CIGARS CANDY
VAPES AND OTHER FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ONLY SERVE TO
MASK THE HARSHNESS OF TOBACCO
AND GET USERS HOPE. TO A DEADLY
LIFELONG ADDICTION. WHAT THE
FDA HAS ESTABLISHED SOME
RESTRICTIONS ON E. CIGARETTES
THESE RULES ARE CLEAR IN A
CLEAR WIN FOR JUL ULTRIUM AND
BIG TOBACCO. THE FEDERAL RULES
EXEMPT ALL MEN FULL FLAVORED E.
CIGARETTES IN ONLY RESTRICTS
FLAVORS IN SOME CARTRIDGE BASED
E. CIGARETTES. LEAVING
THOUSANDS OF FLAVORED E.
CIGARETTES IN EVERY IMAGINABLE
FLAVOR WIDELY AVAILABLE. THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY
INTRODUCED THE NEXT NEW FAD.
CHEAP DISPOSABLE E. CIGARETTES
IN FLAVORS SUCH AS STRAWBERRY
GRAPE AND MANGO YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD OF PUFF BARS OF BARS AND
ELECTRIC ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
THAT LOOKS REMARKABLY SIMILAR
TO JUL DEVICES JUST ONE OF THE
MANY KID FRIENDLY TOBACCO
PRODUCTS EXEMPT UNDER FEDERAL
RULES PUFF BARS COME IN EVERY
FLAVOR IMAGINABLE ARE EASY TO
CONCEAL AND ARE WIDELY
AVAILABLE. I KNOW WE HAVE HAD
TO ACT TO REASSESS. AND CHANGE
OUR PRIORITIES IN RESPONSE TO
THE DEVASTATING COVERT NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC. AT THE VERY LEAST TO
THIS PANDEMIC REINFORCES THE
NEED TO ESTABLISH STRONG
TOBACCO CONTROL POLICY AND
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO STOP
SMOKING. THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WARNS THE TOBACCO
USE CAN INCREASE THE RISK OF
SUFFERING THE MOST SEVERE
SYMPTOMS OF COVERT NINETEEN.
ADDITIONALLY MANY PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS CAUTIONED THAT SMOKING
PUTS PEOPLE AT INCREASED RISK
OF CONTRACTING THE DISEASE.
MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED BUT WE
KNOW CONCLUSIVELY THAT SMOKING
INCREASES RISK OF RESPIRATORY
INFECTION WEAKENS THE IMMUNE
SYSTEM AND IS A MAJOR
UNDERLYING CAUSE OF LUNG
DISEASE HEART DISEASE AND
DIABETES. SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
TAKE SWIFT ACTION TO PROTECT
YOUTH AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS FROM FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE RETAIL SALE OF ALL
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS. OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS LIKE
MENTHOL CIGARETTES HAVE BEEN
USED FOR GENERATIONS AND I
SEEN. TO DATE TARGET
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN LGBT Q.
COMMUNITIES ADDING TO THE
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
POPULATION ALREADY IMPACTED BY
SOCIAL INEQUITIES. BIG TOBACCO
WEAPONIZE THESE TACTICS TO LURE
A NEW GENERATION TO NICOTINE
ADDICTION IT IS TIME THAT WE
BREAK THE CYCLE. MISTER CHAIR
JOINING US REMOTELY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT WE HAVE THREE
WITNESSES WE'RE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR LANEY GOING A LOT THIS
A CO SPONSOR BEST BE SEVEN
NINETY THREE I'M HONORED TO
HAVE HER AS A CO SPONSOR. DR
BONNIE HELP PRINT FELL SURE
CREATOR OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY'S USED TOBACCO
PREVENTION TOOL KIT AND SHE
WILL BE BY EXPERT WITNESS ON
THE SUBJECT MATTER TODAY. IN
ADDITION A- TEN DOLLAR. SPECIAL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AN ANTI
VAPING ADVOCATE THANK YOU
MISTER. ANTI CENTER HELL AND-
SO RECOGNIZING WE HAVE- THREE-
SUPPORTING WITNESSES ON THE
LINE TO TESTIFY- THEY WILL HAVE
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES A
STERN ORDER WHICH YOU WISH ME
TO TAKE THEM UP CERTAINLY I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF WOULD HAVE
A OR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OKAY
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD SO ORDER IN
WHICH AYE. AYE DARING NAME THEM
OKAY- SO I WOULD ASK THAT THE-
MODERATOR- I BELIEVE THERE ARE
THERE ON THE PHONE LINE IS THAT
CORRECT YES I BELIEVE SO YES
THEY ARE THAT IS CORRECT YES
OKAY SO- MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE- FIRST- ELL LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR I CAN A LOT GUESTS TO
TESTIFY PERSON AGAIN A BINDER
TO ALL THE SUPPORTING TEST ANY-
DO YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES TOGETHER SO KEEP IN
MIND- TRY. YOUR LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO IN IT SO THAT EACH
OF THE TEST OF THAT THE FIRE
COULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THEIR REMARKS AGAIN
LIEUTENANT DOUG ARE CONNECTS.
US TURNING GOVERNOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO ENSURE THE YOUR ITEM.
ON YOUR END. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR PAN SENATOR HAILING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY THREE A BILL I AM PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR. I HAVE TWO
TEENAGE SONS AND OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS I'VE WATCHED THE
DRAMATIC RISE USING E.
CIGARETTES AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM UP CLOSE. I'M NOT THE ONLY
PARENT TO WITNESS THIS
EXPLOSION IN E. CIGARETTE USE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OVER FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION KIDS AGES TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN REPORT USING E.
CIGARETTES. FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION KIDS WHEN STUDENTS TO
BAIT ARE ASKED WHAT TYPE OF
PRODUCT THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
PERCENT OF BULLARD STATE LABOR
PRODUCTS HERE IS THE GRAND
BOTTOM LINE LABOR DE CIGARETTES
ALREADY HOOKED AND OTHER
GENERATION OF SMOKERS AND THOSE
MARKETS. THAT CLEAN AIR TO EACH
THIS IS WHY SB SEVEN THREE IS
SELLING COURT ESPECIALLY IN THE
FACE OF OUR CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS BY BANNING
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS WE
CAN STOP MILLIONS MORE OF OUR
CHILDREN. FROM USING A BECOMING
ADDICTED TO TOBACCO THANK YOU
SENATOR HEALTH FOR MOVING IT'S
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR WORK. THANK
YOU LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR- FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT UP WILL BE
DOCTOR BONNIE HALPERN I FEEL
SURE. GOOD MORNING CARE PAN
VICE CHAIR MISTER NELSON THE
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE I'M A PROFESSOR OF
PEDIATRICS DEVELOPMENTAL
PSYCHOLOGIST FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
TOBACCO PREVENTION TOOL KIT I
HAVE OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE RESEARCHING WHY YOU.
USED TOBACCO WITH THE
CIGARETTES AT THE CORE MY WORK
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS THREE MAIN
CONCERNS ABOUT FLAVOR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FIRST THERE OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND E. CIGARETTE
FLAVORS AND NUMEROUS FLAVORS
ANOTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INCLUDING CIGARS IN WHO GOT.
EVERYTHING CLEAN MENTAL MENTAL
ATTRACT YOUNGER NEW USERS NEW
EXCEPT THREE SUCH AS POPCRUSH
ALLOW YOU TO ADD FLAVORS TO
EXISTING BEEPING PRODUCTS MOST
YOUTH SITE FLAVORS AS A REASON
TO USE A REPORT THEY WOULD QUIT
TOBACCO USE IS FLAVORS WEREN'T
AVAILABLE. SECOND FLAVORS MASK
THE HOT THE RISKS THAT ARE
INHERENT IN TOBACCO CLEANING
ALARMINGLY HIGH AMANDA NICOTINE
THAT'S PARTICULARLY HARMFUL FOR
YOU. THIRD DESPITE SOME BELIEVE
NO STATE IN THE WEST HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT ANY PRESS OR
FACT OF TO A CESSATION DEVICES
NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT AS WE
FIGHT CORONAVIRUS IT IS NEVER
BEEN MORE. ALONE HEALTHY COULD
PARSE ATTACKS ALONG AND THERE'S
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT SMOKING
BABY HARM. TO US THERE'S
CONCERN I'M HEALTH EXPERTS THAT
PEOPLE WHO SMOKE OR BATES OR
GREATER RISK FOR SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS FROM KOBE
NINETEEN WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO PREVENT TOBACCO USE
ESPECIALLY AMONG ARE YOU. ALSO
LEVER TOBACCO PRODUCTS WILL
HELP US DO THIS I URGE YOU TO
PASS SB SEVEN NINETY THREE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR KIDS
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. WE PROVIDE
DATA. TO SUPPORT MY CLAIMS
THANK YOU. THANK FINE WE HAVE
MISS A- I DID TIA INDIA I POWER.
I THINK YOU'RE FIRST TWO
SPEAKERS LET YOU PRAY FIFTEEN
SEC. MISS INDIA HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M INTERESTED IN BLOCKS OFF
MARC ALMOND COLLEGE CRAP HOW DO
WE GET YOU ACROSS THE STATE
BUDGET THE AREA RIO EIGHT
GREATER AND PLAN FOR TWO
MARIANA RODRIGUEZ COLLEGE
STUDENT FROM EL CENTRO ARE
TRYING TO PASS LEGISLATION JUST
LIKE THIS ONE CITY AT A TIME.
BUT OUR STATE LEGISLATURE COULD
STEP IN AND MAKE IT HAPPEN WHY
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND USED
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE STOP BIG TOBACCO FROM
LAURIE ANYMORE KIDS TOO
DANGEROUS ADDICTION OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SEVEN
MUCH APPRECIATED. AND HOW IT'S
CHALLENGING ARE DOING IT ON THE
PHONE WITH THE TRANSPORTATION.
THE MONEY. RIGHT THE DID A
GREAT THE A GREAT. ALL RIGHTS
LET'S A MOVE LET'S NOW BEGIN A
WITNESSES WHO AND FORTY TWO OH
THREE OF THE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
THREE. ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THE NONE- WE
WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROPPED
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
ONLY SHOWING SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IT
ZERO AT THIS TIME AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOUR LINE NUMBER
AND FURTHER INSTRUCTIONS OKAY
USING A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. SO FAR AS
OF HE SECOND I HAVE SEVENTEEN
BUT IT WILL INCREASE. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO WHAT IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT SUPPORT AGAIN
REMINDER ITS NAME IF YOU'RE
ASSOCIATED AN ORGANIZATION YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR EXPECT
AND BASICALLY STATING THAT
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN.
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE AT ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING PER SURCHARGE ON BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
AND CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU WANNA GO LINE OF
ONE EIGHTEEN OF ITS ONE ONE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
THIS IS KAREN LAYING ON THAT OF
THE SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU OUR NEXT LINE IS ONE
FIFTY TWO THAT'S ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR FOR MEMBERS
COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA. NURSES ASSOCIATION
CREEK COURT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT LINE IS LINUS
SIXTY THREE SIX THREE LINE IS A
HELLO KITTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEARING NO RESPONSE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT THE NEXT LINE IS
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO ONE
TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
WHICH I AGREE WITH COMMONSENSE
THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF KIDS AND FAMILIES. NOW
THE CO SPONSOR RECENT COURT SB
SEVEN NINE THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN ONE ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MORNING
CRAIG A MOTHER OF TWO TEENAGERS
AND- MEMBER OF THE ANTI TAKING
pSCHOOL I AM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU OUR NEXT LINE
WILL BE LINE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR ME
IT. SORRY APPARENTLY IT'S LINE
ONE FORTY THREE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE COURT-
MEN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT LINE IS
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JIM GIVES THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MISTER SURE WE'D
LIKE TO ENTER ALSO THE SAME
TIME LIKE TO READ OFF A- A LOT
A LIST OF OTHER SUPPORTERS SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CALL IN IS
THAT OKAY. ARE YOU MAY LIST
DILLON YES YOU MAY READ A LIST
OF SUPPORTERS ONLY YES THANK
YOU. OKAY AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AMERICANS.
FOR NON SMOKERS RIGHTS.
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN COLLEGES BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA'S
STUDY OF ADDICTIVE MEDICINE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP CVS.
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA. LABOR'S ADDICT
KIDS LIVERMORE HEALTH ACCESS
ONLY FAMILIES FIGHTING FLAVORED
TOBACCO. TURNS AGAINST- BIKINI
CIGARETTES PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES. PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND FINALLY THE CITY
OF PALO ALTO SAN PABLO SAN
LEANDRO BERKELEY AND OAKLAND
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU AND I.
KIRSTEN TO ALSO US DIRECTLY
SEND- REMARKS ARE NOTES TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH SO THANKS
VERY MUCH. EXPLAINS OUR NEXT
NEXT LINE IN SUPPORTERS ROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JAMIE MARK AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION ACRE SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXUS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
ONE ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I LIVE IN IT YOU KNOW HEALTH
AND THEY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
ARE TAKING SUPPORT TESTIMONY
BUT WE WILL RECORD YOUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. YEAH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE I KNOW THERE I
UNDERSTAND OR SOME OTHER PEOPLE
ON THE LINE THANK THE
MODERATORS TRYING TO GET TO
THEM.
IN NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS LINE IS OPEN IF I HAD.
GOOD MORNING MY AND A HIGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND SAN MATTEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. F. BY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY FIVE I'M SORRY SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JERRY
ON MUTE. LINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR THE
SALUTE. IT IS QUITE GOOD BIG
LATER THANK YOU FOR CALLING AND
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE THEM ALL.
I'LL BE. OKAY I'LL DO IT WHAT
BY FOUR AND THEN GIVE ALL THE
ON THE- AT THIRTEEN DOLLARS ON.
OKAY THAT SOUND THAT'S- AT THIS
POINT. TO MOVE ON THE NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
VOICING SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO LITTLE RESULT IN
ON THE ACT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TOBACCO CONTROL COALITION AND
COACH BUT FOR SUPPORT PRESSED
THE SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS MATTHEW ROBINSON
KAISER PERMANENTE A IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I NUMBER ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS OLGA SHILOH
WITH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT IS THE LAST LINE.
OKAY SO TWO COULD JUST CHECK
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN BE SURE
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN. NINETY THREE. LINE ONE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA INTO PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
MODERATOR. A MOMENT PLEASE. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS CRITICAL DEBATED BUT
THAT CAMPAIGN COULD OF THREE
KIDS THAT PROUD BECAUSE BONTA
THIS MEASURE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OR ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL PEOPLE
ON THE LINE. AND WE CAN WRITE
YOU WITH THAT AND THE ABLE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR HELL. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MY LINE QUEUING UP
OKAY LAST ONE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE
BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ANY FURTHER PEOPLE ON THE
LINE. SUPPORT NO AT THEIR LINE.
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO- HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
BEGIN HEARING FROM THE
OPPOSITION- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OF THE THREE IF YOU CAN
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THINK CENTER HILL
AND OF STAFF MY NAME IS AFRICA
VARGAS AND I'M WITH CASE STREET
CONSULTING AND WE REPRESENT THE
WHO COULD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE'RE NOT HERE TO OPPOSE SB
SEVEN NINETY THREES ATTEMPT TO
LIMIT TEAM VAPING UNDERAGE
VAPING AND TO CURB. UNDERAGE
SMOKING WE ARE HERE TO STAY TO
OPPOSE AND HOOKERS INCLUSION IN
THIS BILL- HOOKER IS A PART OF
THE CULTURAL HERITAGE THERE'S
BEEN AROUND FOR NEARLY A
THOUSAND YEARS WHO IS THE
CENTERPIECE OF CULTURAL
BUSINESS AND SOCIAL MEETINGS
FOR MANY MANY CULTURES AND
CUSTOMS- HOOKAH WATER PIPE IS
APPROXIMATELY ONE TO FOUR FEET
TALL ABOUT THE LENGTH OF MY
FOREARM FROM ELBOW TO MY THE
END OF MY FINGERTIPS. STAND IN
RESPECT SENATOR HILL DESIRED
LIMIT UNDERAGE VAPING AND UPON
FOR IS A DEDICATION AND HIS
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE- CENTER
HILL AND HIS STAFF HAVE BEEN
VERY ACCESSIBLE. AND WE MET
PERSONALLY WITH CENTER HOME WE
THANK HIM FOR THAT MEETING. SO
WE ASK IN AN AT THAT MEETING WE
ASKED TO BE EXEMPTED FROM THE
BILL UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
STILL NOT SEEN ANY AMENDMENTS.
WERE OF THE SHOWN ANY INTEREST
IN EXEMPTING HOOKAH. AFTER THE
SENATOR RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT
CERTAIN FLAVORS AND PACKAGING
WE WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY. TO
SELF REGULATE AND THEY HAVE
REMOVED CERTAIN FLAVOR NAMES
AND PACKAGING AND CONTINUE TO
WORK. TO THAT END. BUT IF MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE LEGISLATION IS
BE PUT FORTH SPECIFIC TO HOOKAH
WE CAN ORK ON THAT AND WE
WELCOME THAT- BUT THAT IS NOT
IN THIS BILL. NOR HAS THERE
EVER BEEN INTERESTED IN HAVING-
SOME REAL- DISCUSSION ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT WE
WELCOME THEM AND ARE AVAILABLE
BUT YET WE ARE HERE AND WE
CONTINUED TO BE FORCED INTO A
POSITION TO OPPOSE. LEGISLATION
ON TEEN VAPING BECAUSE IT
INCLUDES TOOK UP AND WE DO NOT
WANT THAT. EVEN CENTER
EXCEEDING EVEN GOVERNOR NEWSOME
IN A PRESS CONFERENCE ON
SEPTEMBER SIXTEENTH. LAST YEAR
STATED THAT QUOTE HOOKAH IS NOT
THE PROBLEM IN CLASSROOMS
SENATORS ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF CONSTITUENTS EACH
OF YOU HAVE IN YOUR DISTRICT
THAT ENJOY HOOKAH. WE ASK YOU
FOCUS THIS BILL ON ITS ORIGINAL
INTENT WHICH IS UNDER AGE
SMOKING AND VAPING AND WE ASK
THE TRADITIONAL HOOKAH. TOBACCO
BE GRANTED A CULTURAL
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU. Q. AND I
WOULD NOTE THAT SINCE WE DIDN'T
RECEIVE A- SOME OF THE AND
REGISTER FORMALLYIN TERMS OF
NOT YET IN TERMS OF BEING
DEPOSITION TESTIMONY WE ALLOW.
SIR OF ARGUS THE TIME FOR THAT
TESTIMONY THAN. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM IN THIS
ROOM ROOM TO. FORTY TWO OR
THREE AND OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEEING NONE- WITNESSES IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING
NONE- WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR THIS- MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROMPT PUBLIC COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO- SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THIS. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME ONE
AND THEN ZERO. OKAY AND AS THE
MODERATOR AND SADDLE UP BEING
OPPOSITION- COMMENTS- I WOULD
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT FIRST OF
ALL THAT- I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
LINES WE DID HAVE SOME ALSO IN
SUPPORT WHO. UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
THE TIME FRAME WE GET TO. THE
NOT ABLE TO GET AND- MODERATOR
AT CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S TOO MANY TO
COUNT DAY OFF MY SCREEN
ACTUALLY A FIFTY NINE. OKAY SO
WHAT WE WILL DO IS WE'LL TAKE
AS MANY AS POSSIBLE- BUT I WILL
BE OUR CAP TO IT ACTUALLY FOR
THE PROPONENTS ACTIONS THAT I
THINK THEY TOOK UP A LITTLE
OVER TEN MINUTES I WILL CAP IT
AT FIFTEEN MINUTES OF.
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY SOMETHING
WE DON'T HAVE SOME MAJOR
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY IN THE
PROCESS RECOGNIZING THAT WE DID
ALSO HAVE PROPONENTS BECAUSE OF
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE LINES WHO
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET ON I WOULD
REMIND PEOPLE YOU CAN. CONTINUE
MAKE COMMENTS TO OUR WEBSITE
ARE DIRECTLY COMMITTEE- THROUGH
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL
SO IF THE TELEPHONE LINE IS YOU
ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH THE
MODERATOR- KEY PLEASE- PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION
TO SB. AT TWO SEVENTY. TWO
NIGHTS AT THE START OPPOSITION
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL FIRST LITTLE
LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
LOOKS LIKE WE LOST LINUS AGAIN
AGAIN IT'S NAME ASSOCIATION AND
ISN'T THANK YOU. I'M SORRY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN JAMES DO YOU
KNOW WHO COULD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- SAY BLUE KERR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBERS THIRTY NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS UP ALL THE WELL
KNOWN FOR MOST EXPERT IN UNITED
STATES AND THE TACTICAL
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. I HOPE
THAT'S ME SEVEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS A C. MOBILE
LIVING YOU EACH AND I'M WITH
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THAT
GOES SB SEVEN NINETY THREE THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ALONG TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SERGIO GOOD
ARE YOU FROM IDDLE GRADE
CALIFORNIA. AND OF THE DEIL
COULD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY TO EXIT
THE COOK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS A REBEKAH
Q. I LIVE IN LA CRESCENTA AYE
OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
STATE YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVEN SIX JOIN
IS OPEN. HELLO ONE SEVEN SIX
LOW ON IT OPEN BUT I THINK.
HELLO YES PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND IF THERE'S ANY
ORGANIZATION WITH AND YOUR
POSITION. ARE YOU A BRAND NEW
PRESIDENT OF GOOGLE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THE SAME GO FOR EXAMPLE TO GO
FROM THIS BILL I THANK YOU
SENATORS. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I EITHER A BLADE-
PRESIDING NDA GO CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MY NAME
IS JAKE JACOBSEN OF WORK ON A
NUMBER OF THE LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AS WELL AS WHO TO
EXPEL WORLDWIDE STRONGLY
OPPOSING THE INCLUSION OF
GOOGLE PRODUCTS AND SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE IN THE INTEREST OF
SAVING RIKA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WELL GOAL LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE ONE
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO. HELLO PLEASE SAY
YOUR NAME ONLY FIVE PLEASE
SPEAK. OKAY INTEREST OF TIME
THEN SINCE THERE'S NO RESPONSE
FROM OF ALONG TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN LINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GREATER HERE COREY.
COREY I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO AND
MEMBERS OF THE CHAMBER CONTACT
COMMERCE AYE OPPOSED AT THE
SEVEN NINETY THREE. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
FORTY FIVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT RIGHT MORE A
MONIES PRIME BALDWIN- I WOULD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- I AM WHAT
I AM NOT GOING TO BE SEVEN
NINETY THREE WE NEED TO GO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI OMAR HERE
LIVE THEY'LL BE ITS CALIFORNIA.
AND I OPPOSE THE SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE. BILLION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
ZERO NINE GO HEAD. HI MY NAME
IS A BILLION A LIMóN DOWNLOAD
AND I AM. GOOD OF COMMERCE I
OPPOSE THIS. THEY WILL GO
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT A LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR
PLEASE. MY IS A FIVE STAR BUT I
LIVE LONG BEACH AND I'M
SUPPOSED AS THE NINE THREE SO
WHO OF. THANK YOU. HE'S GOT A
LINE ONE HOW AND THREE ONE ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME THE COLBERT
SACRAMENTO AND I'M WITH THE WHO
COULD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE AND USING THE CORONA
VIRUS ENDEMIC AS JUSTIFICATION
FOR THIS THOUGH. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY NINE SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SAM
HANNON I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO AND
I'M WITH THE WHO COULD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. SB SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN ONE
THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI MY NAME IS SEAN PENN
ALTHOUGH I LIVE IN HACIENDA
HEIGHTS- I AM WITH THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND I OPPOSE- SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE BAKER. YOU
YOU GOT ONLINE SEVENTY NINE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CHANTE HOW CAN I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
ONE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ARE RESERVED ALREADY
LIVING GLENDALE CITY- I'M WITH
THE LOCAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ALL THIS YOU SEVEN NINE THREE
THREE THEY ARE OUR CULTURE AND
TRADITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
COULD SPELL LOW PRICED- SO I DO
JUST ONE MAKE NOTE THAT-
APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE TESTIFYING SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THE ISSUE AROUND TOO
BECAUSE WE DID HEAR FORMAL
TESTIMONY AS WELL CERTAINLY IF
YOU WE STILL WISH TO CONTINUE
TO COMMENTS I DON'T WANT TO.
ALLOW YOU TO CONTINUE TO DO SO
FOR THAT WE STILL ALLOW SOME
TIME TO DO THAT BUT IF THERE'S
OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
OPPOSITION FOR OTHER REASONS
HOPE PERHAPS WE CAN LET THEM
ALSO HAVE A CHANCE TO. MAKE
THEIR REMARKS IF THERE ARE ANY
BODY ELSE SO WE HAVE HEARD YOU
THAT- FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT TO GET
EXEMPTION- BUT ANYWAY MODERATOR
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIFTY TWO. FIVE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH MATTER IN SAN DIEGO
AND I'M WITH THE WHO COULD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AYE OPPOSED
AS BE NINE THREE DAYS OKAY.
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS AMERICAN
MEN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I'M WITH THE- HOOKER LOCAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND ARMY
CORPS OF THE SEVEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. FIND ONE
SIXTY TWO ONE SIX TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBER
LAURA BETTER WITH CALIFORNIAN
VISORS ON BEHALF OF THE PAPER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION NOT THE
VERSION THAT SEVEN NINETY THREE
WE JUST RECEIVED OUR TO OUR
LETTER IN OPPOSITION AS WELL
WHAT THE TIME THAT. THANK YOU.
GET WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO ONE THREE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS NANCY
HERNANDEZ. I'M FROM PANAMA CITY
COCA YOU. THANK YOU OF A LINE
THIRTY THREE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM ALL THAT
DELAYED UP FROM SAN DIEGO. AND
AYE OPPOSED TO BE SEVEN NINETY
THREE. OKAY THANK YOU. IF YOU
LOOK ONLINE EIGHTY NINE EIGHT
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CHARLES THREE CANYON I LIVE
IN HENDERSON NEVADA AND I AM
WITH THE WHO COULD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I OPPOSE SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. Q. THE
LINE NINETY NINE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS EDWARD
THREE I LIVE IN NORTH HILLS AND
I WOULD HOPE THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I'LL POST SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. PEOPLE COMPLAIN.
A LINE ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN ACROSS THE
ISLAND BURBANK CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE INCLUSION
OF GO GO AGAIN AS BE SEVEN NINE
THREE PLEASE SEND GROUP THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND
SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALEX
MATH I LIVE IN STUDIO CITY I
STAND WITH A COOKIE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSING THIS
MILITARY SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
PLEASE ENABLE. YOU. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE THIRTY EIGHT
THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS NINA MALICK I OWN TO
LOOK AROUND JUST IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES I OPPOSE THE BILL.
UP TO CIRCLE THANK. WHAT A LINE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ERIN NORWOOD ON TOP OF SWEDISH
MATCH NORTH AMERICA WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB SEVEN NINETY THREE I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
SMOKELESS TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN
ALTERNATIVE NICOTINE PRODUCTS
SUCH AS OUR POCKETS IN. THE
EXEMPTED FROM THE BELL
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
SMOKELESS PRODUCTS OKAY A ONE
POINT 7% YOU SAID RIGHT THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT TAKING ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY THAT I DID WANT TO
GIVE YOU SOMETIME TO DESCRIBE
YOUR AMENDMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO. THANK YOU AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
TWO SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MARLENE A KOREA I'M
FROM THE JAIL. I APPROACH.
EIGHT SEVEN NINE THREE THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE ONE THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS OUT OF IT
THEN THE- LIVE IN FULLER IN AND
THEY OPPOSE IT THE SEVEN NINETY
THREE HEY HOOKAH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY NINE FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS VICTOR JOHN I'M A
NUMBER OF THE LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BANK CALLED IN TODAY
TO OPPOSE THAT SEVEN EIGHT NINE
IN REGARDS TO A HOOKAH PRODUCTS
AND- STAVING ARE GONNA CULTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE ONE A
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS JOHN HACKER I LIVE IN
BURBANK CALIFORNIA I AM BEGGING
YOU TO EXEMPT THE MCCA FROM
THIS BILL THEY PROGRAM. I THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT ONE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS DANIELLE JONES I AM
A VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR
SMOKE FREE ALTERNATIVES SB
NATION OPPOSING SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
WELL ARE YOU IN THE TWENTY A
LOAN ON THEM THE BILL COULD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AYE OPPOSED
THE SEVEN NINETY THREE A LOCAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TWELVE TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RINA COREY
I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO AND A
MEMBER OF THE GROUP CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AYE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINE THREE SAY COCA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FORTY SIX FOUR
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE FIND
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME ALLOWED THE LIFE I
LIVED IN THE DIRECTOR LOOK FOR
YEAH AND I'M WITH THE- OF THAT
JENNIFER COMMERCE AND I AM
FORTY SEVEN HE- SEVEN NINETY
THREE. OKAY THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME'S LOANS BONDS I'M WITH
LEGAL HOOKAH. I HAVE CLOSED SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE PLEASE SAVE
YEAH THANK YOU YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT ONE SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME JUDGE BABY ON
WITH TO GO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE THINK WE'VE GOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD AT. NINE ONE THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RELEASING THAT
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOU
WANT IS OPEN. FIND SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY FOUR NINE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS PAUL REVIEW AND I LIVE IN
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
WITH THE WHO COULD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND I OPPOSE SB SEVEN
NINE THREE THEY GO BACK. THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DAVID MYERS AND I WITH THEM
THEN NUYS CALIFORNIA WE COULD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ARTICLES AS
THE SEVEN NINETY THREE PLEASE
SAVE COCA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANDREW CELLS ARE LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I AM WITH THE WITH
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ALL
OF YOU TO PLEASE SAVE WHO GOT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LARGEST
YOU'RE IN A LOSING BATTLE AND
AYE OPPOSED OF THE BILL BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF- EXEMPTION FOR
TRADITIONAL GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHECK. THANK YOU LINE
NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
CAROL MORALIS I LIVE IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE THREE
SAY FOCA. THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND YOU ASK YOU TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT. HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE ARE ONLINE. THERE ARE
ELEVEN MORE IN Q. OKAY WELL WE
HAVE REACHED OUR CAP ON PUBLIC
COMMENT. ABOUT OVER FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
ERROR I'D- AND INTERESTS OF
TIME NORM BECAUSE OF. THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN TODAY AND
THE AGENDA- FORTUNATE I DON'T
THINK- WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL ON THE
LINE- TO PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS VIA OUR WEBSITE. OR
YOU CAN SENT DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I KNOW
THAT- WE'VE HAD POSTED-
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO-
TESTIFIED VERBALLY HERE OVER
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE BUT IF
BECAUSE OF- TIMER STRAIGHT TIME
CAPS OR- TECHNICAL ISSUES. I DO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO SUBMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY ONLINE
APPRECIATE AGAIN EVERYONE
STATIONS AND- YOUR INPUT TO
THIS PROCESS- SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO WHO
DID TESTIFY AND WHO IS ON THE
LINE AND AGAIN- REQUEST YOUR-
ASSISTANCE AND INTELLIGENCE AND
THE FACT UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY VERBALLY AT. THIS
TIME- SO WITH THAT- I WANT TO
MOVE TO- QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
ARE FROM MEMBERS. SENATE AWAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR-
HILL I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BACK I
WAS HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR
LAST YEAR I AM HAPPY AND PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR THIS YEAR IT
IS SHOCKING AND DISAPPOINTING
TO ME THAT OUR STUDENTS AT OUR
HIGH SCHOOLS ARE TRYING TO. TO
CHANGE VAPING AND HELP THEIR
PEERS STAY SAFE AND THE ADULTS
HAVE DONE NOTHING ABOUT IT IT
IS SO CLEAR THE EVIDENCE IS SO
CLEAR THA OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
BABY BECAUSE OF THE FLAVORS
THIS BILL TO ME IS PERFECT IF
WE TAKE AWAY THE FLAVOR AND
PEOPLE STILL ONE OF EIGHT
THAT'S GREAT THEY CAN JUST
TASTE THE TASTE OF THE
NICOTINE. BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE
DOING THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO-
CREATE A LIFELONG ADDICTION FOR
OUR YOUTH WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING THINGS THAT HELP OUR
YOUTH TO BE THE BEST THEM THAT
THEY CAN BE SO I CAN'T THANK
YOU ENOUGH FOR BRINGING IT OF
FORWARD AGAIN HAPPY TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND I HOPE ALL OF US
ADULTS CAN DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR OUR YOUTH SO THAT THEY'RE
NOT AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS AND-
HI. TRYING TO FIX BUT WE
COULDN'T FIX SO I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SAID
EARLIER I THANK SUPPORT. THANK
YOU US IN RUBIO. THANK YOU- I
ALSO ON A SYSTEM OUT ONTO THE
SENATORS COMMENT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HEAR OFTEN WOULD
REALLY IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BOTHERSOME TO ME AS I HEAR THAT
IT'S NOT TARGETING OUR KIDS
LAST YEAR I MEAN I WENT OUT TO
RESEARCH THE ISSUE AND REALLY-
FIGURE OUT HOW KIDS WERE
GETTING THEIR HANDS ON THESE
PRODUCTS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I FOUND AND I ACTUALLY
BODY FOR DISPLAY HERE. IS THE
NUMBER OF PRODUCTS FROM PENCILS
STAPLERS- ON A YOU KNOW EVEN
SHIRTS THAT HAD LITTLE TUBES
THAT KIDS WOULD SMOKE IN THE
LIBRARY IN THE LUNCH AREA AND
W. FORMER TEACHER I ALSO TALKED
TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES- IN
SCHOOLS AND THEY SAID THAT THEY
CAN KEEP TRACK ANYMORE BECAUSE
KIDS WERE CORNERING THEMSELVES
EITHER IN THE LIBRARY OR YOU
KNOW IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
SCHOOLS. SO I ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THEY'RE TARGETING OUR
KIDS AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THAT WE DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT AND THE SENATOR-
LEVI'S CORRECT THAT WE NEED TO
DO RIGHT BY OUR KIDS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
OKAY THANK YOU AYE SIR GROVE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE A QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SENATOR HELEN AND
THEM. SO I JUST I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
IT AND I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THE CHAIR IS CAN INDULGE IT
BUT- SO I. A BASED ON WHAT
SENATOR RUBIO JUST SAID MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SAID ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW- THESE PRODUCTS ARE
LIKE HIDDEN THINGS LIKE- TENS
OR OR- I DON'T KNOW WHATEVER
THEY ARE THAT PLUGS INTO
COMPUTERS THINGS LIKE THAT. AND
THEIR THIRD THEY LOOK LIKE THEY
DON'T LOOK LIKE WHAT YOU WOULD
THINK THEY LOOK LIKE IT'S IT
LIKE A DISGUISE. AM I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IT- I LOOK AT THESE
THINGS LIKE FOR CANNABIS AND
THEM YOU KNOW GUMMY BEARS LOLLY
POPS COOKIES. THE ALL THESE
THINGS THAT ARE ARE HIDDEN
THINGS AS WELL YOU KNOW LIKE
GUMMY BEARS. LOOK LIKE CANDY TO
KIDS. BUT THERE CANNABIS M.
IT'S CANNABIS AND I NOTICE
THAT. YOU MADE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THE INCREASE IN THE USAGE
OF AB IN- FOR FLAVOR PRODUCTS
BUT MARIJUANA LEGAL
LEGALIZATION SINCE IT'S BEEN
INCEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND SIX-
IT'S ROSY EXPOSURES WAS ABOUT A
148% AND EVEN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
ON EXECUTIVE ORDER HE
HIGHLIGHTED RATES OF YOUTH USE
OF THE CIGARETTES AT TEN POINT
FOUR PERCENT. AND WHILE
CANNABIS WAS AT FOURTEEN POINT
9% SO IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE
DATA SHOWS THAT CANNABIS IS
MORE- AFFECTING OUR YOUTH MORE
THAN WHAT THE E. CIGARETTE
FLAVORS ARE. AND SO I GUESS
GIVEN THAT THE CDC IS ALSO
ATTRIBUTED THAT THE RECENT LUNG
INFECTION AND THE OUTBREAK OUR
OUR TTC VAPING PRODUCTS AND
WE'RE NOT USING THAT ARGUMENT
FOR THIS ANYMORE- IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT THE CANNABIS RATES. THAT
AFFECTED ARE YOU SHOULD BE MORE
ALARMING DâN AND- THEN-WHAT
THESE LABOR EAT CIGARETTES ARE
DOING SO AS- CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT- BE HAPPY TO LISTEN TO
GROW THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND- I GUESS WHAT WE LOOK AT IN
THIS BILL IS CONCENTRATED ON.
THE PREVALENCE AND THE
DEVASTATING EFFECT OF TOBACCO
AND NICOTINE ADDICTION. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE ADDICTION OR
THE ADDICTIVE ASPECTS OF
CANNABIS. OR ALCOHOL WE FIND
THAT 31% OF TOBACCO USERS TO
DEVELOP DEPENDENCE ON TOBACCO
SO IT'S A VERY ADDICTIVE.
PRODUCT THAT- CERTAINLY
CONTROLS THEIR LIFE AFTER THAT
ADDICTION BUT WE'RE AS- A
DEPENDENT ON TOBACCO COMPARED
TO FIFTEEN POINT 5% FOR. THE
WHOLE YOU. ONLY AND ONE. ASIAN
ONLY EVEN THOUGH IT SIGNIFICANT.
9% OF CANNABIS USERS ACTUALLY
BECOME ADDICTED TO THE PRODUCT
SO WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
MOST. PREVALENT THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND THE MOST
ADDICTIVE PRODUCT ON THE MARKET
TODAY. TO PREVENT- THAT TYPE OF
ADDICTION BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
HAVE- YOU KNOW DR- HELP INFILL
SURE IF- YOU'D LIKE TO GIVE
MORE. THE EVIDENCE IN TERMS OF
THE SCIENTIFIC ASPECT OF THE
ADDICTION AND THE NEED FOR.
TOBACCO FLAVOR PROHIBITION
RATHER THAN THE CANNABIS ISSUE.
OKAY OKAY HELLO DOES MAKE NOTE
GIVEN THE TIME CONSTRAINTS OF
SIR GROW WOULD IT BE HELPFUL
FOR YOU TO HEAR FROM DOCTOR
ABOUT THIS OR NOT. EAT WHAT YOU
CAN YOU JUST HAPPENS TO MY
OFFICE BECAUSE THE CHURCH
CONCERNED HAPPY TO. CATCH I
AGREE WITH THAT IDEA THANK YOU
SO I'M I ALSO KNOW THAT. I'M
YEAH I KEEP THINKING HOW WE-
THESE TWO IN. IN THE CAMPUS
INDUSTRY IS GETTING  TAX
REDUCTION AND THERE'S ANOTHER
BILL THAT REQUIRES A TAX
INCREASE ON IN THE BUT AND THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT'S
COMING OUT. AND THEY'VE
DISCUSSED A TAX INCREASE ON-
THESE E. CIGARETTE PRODUCTS.
AND THEY'RE ESTIMATING THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE PRIDE SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX LOSSES IF THIS
BILL PASSES. SO THAT CREATES A
BUDGET ISSUE THAT WE HAVE- AS
WELL. I JUST THINK THAT WE
COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY- INSTEAD
OF BANNING OR DECIMATED AN
ENTIRE INDUSTRY. WE COULD
FIGURE OUT A WAY FOR I DON'T
KNOW FEES FOR HIGHER ON THE YOU
KNOW FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT SELL
TO MINORS A PARENT SOMETIMES AT
SOME TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY-
IN. BUT WE'VE GOT TO STOP
ATTACKING THE PRIVATE BUSINESS
INDUSTRY. IS I GUESS MY ISSUE.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS. I GUESS I'LL STOP
THERE THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROCER
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SORT OF PAN FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO A KNOWLEDGE ARE CHEERING
EVERYONE HERE OUR NEW SET UP
YOU NOT YOU SAID TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'RE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WITH THIS HAVING
TO KIND OF ALL THE JUST. TO OUR
NEW. CLIMATE IN WHICH WE ARE
DOING POLICY MAKING SO LET ME
CHECK MY HAVE TO EVERYONE WHO'S
MADE THIS POSSIBLE IT SEEMS TO
BE GOING. SEEMS TO ME THAT THE-
THE SCREEN THE SWITCH IN AND
IT'S ALL WORKING FOR THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN- SENATOR HE'LL JUST
A QUICK QUESTION- BASED ON THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WITH REGARD TO
FOCUS ON THE BALLOT IN THE
CULTURAL RELEVANCE OF WHO COULD
YOU TALK TO ME COULD YOU TELL%
ME WHY YOU'VE CHOSEN NOT TO
AMENDED OUT OF THE BILL I THINK
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US
ALL TO NOW. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL AND YOU KNOW I
RECOGNIZE AND I THINK WE CAN
ALL APRECIATE THE CULTURAL
COMPONENT OF HOOKAHS. THERE'S
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT. BUT AT
THIS POINT AT THIS STAGE I HAVE
A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
UNDERSTANDING. THE CULTURAL
RELEVANCE OF HAVING FLAVORS.
LIKE WHITE GUMMY BEAR OR RED
GUMMY BEAR OR YOU MAY WANT
COCOA JUMBO OR SEX ON THE
BEACH. PIRATES CAVER BUBBLE
GUM. THAT'S THE CHALLENGE HAT
I'M LOOKING AT- IN TERMS OF
EXEMPTING. A PARTICULAR
CULTURAL BECAUSE I HAVE TO
STRUGGLING WITH THE CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF THOSE FLAVORS.
I HATE THAT SO THE- COMMENT.
SAFE SO YOUR BILL WOULD NOT
STOP. HOOKAH LOUNGES ARE THOSE
WHO CHOOSE TO. SMOKE HOOKAH
FROM DOING SELL IT WOULD ONLY
STOP THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
FLAVORED PRODUCTS THAT'S
CORRECT A BIG IN THE FLAVORED
PRODUCT WOULD STILL BE
AVAILABLE ONLINE JUST AS THEY
WOULD STILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER TOBACCO CIGARETTES IT UP
YOU CAN PURCHASE THEM ONLINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE MISTER CHAIR I'D BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER MINING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I ALSO JUST WANT
TO AND MINE. THANKS TO THE
STAFF PREPARATION IN SUPPORT
FOR TODAY IN IN THE PUBLIC
SUPPORT AS WELL FOR. MOVING
FORWARD A AND THANKS TO THE
CHAIR FOR YOUR STAFF AN
ACCOMMODATION AS FAR THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I FULLY INTENDED TO
MOVE THE BILL BUT I WAS BEATEN
TO THE PUNCH BY MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE SENATOR MITCHELL. I
KNOW YOU'VE WORKED ON THIS- IN
MY DISTRICT SENATOR RUBIO
REFERENCE SOME OF THE-
SMUGGLING DEVICES USED IN
SCHOOLS- ALSO THUMB DRIVES FOR
COMPUTERS MADE TO LOOK LIKE A
THUMB DRIVE THAT'S ACTUALLY-
FOR VAPING- I'VE HEARD FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT USED TO-
SUSPEND STUDENTS WHEN THEY WERE
CAUGHT WITH VAPING PRODUCTS.
THEY WERE LOSING TOO MUCH
EIGHTY A MONEY BECAUSE OF THE
PREVALENCEIN SO STUDENTS WERE
SENT TO STUDY HALLS AFTER THE
EQUIPMENT WAS CONFISCATED.
QUICK QUESTION IS THE USE OF
VAPING MATERIAL. LEGAL FOR
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. NO IT'S NOT LEGAL
THE MARKETING TARGETS USE FROM
IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS MIDDLE
SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL AGE YOUTH
MOST OF WHOM ARE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE. SO IT'S AN
ILLEGAL PRODUCT FOR THEM TO
POSSESS ALREADY BUT THE
MARKETING CONTINUES LEADING
WITH THE FLAVORS TO APPEAL TO
CHILDREN IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE- THE
HISTORY OF THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
AND HOW THEY MARKET TO YOUTH
AND- A- AND A X. TWO OF THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IN THEIR
FLAVORED TOBACCO IS EVEN BY
OFFERING AT A LOWER PRICE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO IT'S MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR THEM TO THEN
BECOME ADDICTED- I DON'T THINK
WE WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT THOSE
WHO- USED. FOR TASTE I MEAN I
TRY TO FIGURE OUT I THINK I WAS
THIRTEEN AND NOTHING TASTED SO
BAD I NEVER PICKED UP ANOTHER
ONE. BUT HAD IT TASTED LIKE
BUBBLE GUM OR SEX ON THE BEACH
AND WITH THAT TASTES LIKE BUT
IT- IT COULD BE VERY ATTRACTIVE
TO SOMEONE- SO HITS- I AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE FIND WITH
THE YOUTH MARKET IS THE FLAVOR
BECOMES ATTRACTIVE IN THE NAMES
MAKE IT. MORE ENTICING AND THEN
THEY BECOME ADDICTED AND IS IT
ACCURATE TO SUGGEST THAT. YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO TAKE UP VAPING WITH
FLAVORED PRODUCTS ARE NOT
SEEKING TO RECOVER FROM. A
PRIOR TOBACCO ADDICTION FROM
CIGARETTES. THIS IS THEIR ON
RAMP THERE ON RAMP AND 80% OF
THEM START WITH A FLAVORED
PRODUCT. AND THEN AFTER THE
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT ONCE THEY
BECOME ADDICTED THEN IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT THE FLAVOR IS THEY
NEED THE FIX AND THEY NEED THE
NICOTINE. AND THEY DON'T BEST
THAT WHAT WE FOUND WITH
EIGHTEEN AND OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT ARE USED IN THE EAST
BRANCH IT'S NOT JUST USING IT
TO TRANSITION OFF OF TOBACCO IS
THEY BECOME ADDICTED AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TRANSITION TO
REGULAR TOBACCO CIGARETTES. SO
IT ACTUALLY WORKS A PERVERT.
THANK YOUNG AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- ON THE IN. I WILL
BE SUPPORT THE BILL TO THANK
YOU. OKAY YOU WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS
I JUST WANT TO A TIME CHECK
WE'RE SO ON OUR FIRST ITEM AND
IT IS TEN OH SEVEN CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I DIDN'T
REALIZE IT WAS STILL GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE ONLINE. AND SO
EASY SO THE FAVORITES AT THE
FLAVOR PRODUCT WILL STILL BE
AVAILABLE ONLINE TO PERK. SO
HOW DO WE STOP STUDENTS OR
CHILDREN FROM GETTING IT
ONLINE. WELL LEGISLACIóN I HAD
LAST YEAR SB THIRTY NINE
REQUIRES NOW THE TOBACCO. SALE
OF TOBACCO ONLINE OR DELIVERY
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS IS TREATED
NO DIFFERENTLY THAN ALCOHOL
SALES ONLINE. THAT PRODUCT HAS
TO BE PACKAGED IN A- CONTINUOUS
IN A IN A WAY IN A MANNER THAT
IDENTIFIES IT AS A TOBACCO
PRODUCT ALSO IDENTIFIES IT IT'S
REQUIRED TO BE DELIVERED TO
SOMEONE OVER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE. AND A SIGNATURE IS
REQUIRED UPON DELIVERY. TO THIS
IS NO DIFFERENT THAN ALCOHOL.
SO IF YOU HAVE TO BE TWENTY ONE
TO VAPE AND YOU HAVE TO BE
TWENTY ONE TO DRINK ALCOHOL.
WE'RE NOT BANNING ALCOHOL AND
STUDENTS AND CHILDREN STILL
HAVE AN ADDICTION TO ALCOHOL
AND THEY STILL PURCHASE
ALCOHOL. I JUST SEE THAT IF
IT'S GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
ONLINE THE ONLY THING THAT WE
DO IS RE REDUCE- AGAIN THE
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT SELL
THIS PRODUCT THEY ASK FOR AN ID
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE STORE.
AND OBVIOUSLY ONLINE YOU CAN-
IT BE EASIER TO MISREPRESENT
WHO YOU ARE TO PURCHASE IT. BUT
IT WOULD ALSO- DIDN'T THEN
GOING INTO ONE OF THESE PLACES
OBVIOUSLY BUT TWELVE YEAR OLD
GOES INTO A STORE THEY CAN
IDENTIFY THAT PERSON
IMMEDIATELY IS A TWELVE YEAR
OLD. THEY'RE NOT GONNA SELLING
THE PRODUCT OR THE SHOULD NOT
SOME THE PRODUCT AND IT'S
ILLEGAL SOUND PRODUCT. BUT HOW
DO YOU KNOW A TWELVE OR
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD IS GOING TO
JUST GO ONLINE AND ORDER IT- I
MEAN MY TEN YEAR OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER IS BETTER ON A
COMPUTER THAN I AM. WELL THAT
WOULD BE FINE WITH THE IDEA.
THEN THAT PERSON WHO RECEIVES
THAT PRODUCT- THAT TOBACCO
PRODUCT OR THAT ALCOHOL PRODUCT
AT THE DOOR. OR WHEREVER TO
RECEIVE HAVE TO BE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE HAVE TO PROVE THAT
THEY'RE TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE
AND HAS TO SIGN FOR THAT. THAT
PRODUCT OF YOUR TWELVE YEARS
OLD I DON'T THINK YOU COULD
PASS FOR TWENTY ONE. AT BY THE-
UPS DRIVER THE FED EX DRIVER
THAT'S REQUIRED TO. TO REQUIRE
THAT SIGNATURE AND
IDENTIFICATION. AND I'M JUST
I'M NOT TRYING TO ARGUE WITH
YOU BUT I JUST SEE THAT. IF
YOU'RE ALREADY REQUIRED TO BE
TWENTY ONE TO PURCHASE SAID AT
A STORE- SO. IN PEOPLE ARE
STILL DOING IT SO IT'LL IS NOT.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE OUR YEAH I
DON'T EITHER BUT- MISTER CHAIR
THAT THE- THAT HAS NOT BEEN A
PROBLEM. WITH ALCOHOL SALES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE FELT THAT IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO APPLY
THAT SAME REQUIREMENT. TO
TOBACCO SALES. I JUST THINK AM
AGAIN VOICING MY OPPOSITION IN
THE BILL. A BECAUSE I THINK IT
DECIMATES A LOT OF- BUSINESSES
IT READ AND IT OBVIOUSLY IS A
CULTURAL ISSUE. AS WELL- AND-
IT OBVIOUSLY IS VERY IMPACTFUL
TO A CERTAIN PARTICULAR
CULTURE. AND THAT IT ALSO
DECIMATES THE KNOWN- THE ONLY
TAX REVENUE FOR THE STATE. BUT
THERE HAS TO BE ANOTHER WAY
THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE OF STUDENTS GETTING A
HOLD OF THIS PRODUCT- WITHOUT
DECIMATING AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY-
SO THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST A QUICK
FOLLOW P I JUST DO NOT THINK
THAT WE CAN SELL OUR CHILDREN
SOUL. FOR MONEY. AND IF THIS IS
STRICTLY ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THEN BEING ABLE TO SELL IT.
THEN WE ARE SAYING THAT MAKING
MONEY IS MORE IMPORTANT. THAN
THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN AND
I THINK THA'S FUNDAMENTALLY
WRONG. SO I CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. SEEN OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. TING
I JUST WANT TO SAY CENTER HELL
OF A THANK YOU FOR. BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD PROUD TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THE BILL. I AND
WE NEED TO. WORK TO TRY TO
REDUCE- TOBACCO EXPOSURE
VERTICALLY NICOTINE EXPOSURE-
TO OUR USE. AND SO WHAT I CAN
WHAT THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING
DIED DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE. IT
WOULD IF I COULD MISS RICHARD
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
THE WITNESSES- TURNER WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR. AND OTHER DOCTOR
AND OUR STUDENTS TO WHO HAVE
BEEN ON THE LINE TODAY AS OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WELL I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT TO
THE BONUSES TO THIS BILL OF
MADE I DO NOT WANT TO LOSE
SIGHT OF THE BIGGER PICTURE.
WITH TOBACCO USE BEING THE
LEADING CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE
DEATH AND DISEASE WE ALSO NEED
TO BE COGNIZANT OF THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES. OF A NEW
GENERATION HOOKED TO NICOTINE.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE DIE
EVERY DAY DUE TO TOBACCO
RELATED ILLNESSES AND- THAT I
CANNOT SEE IF THERE'S ANY
REASON THAT THE MOST DEADLY
PRODUCT. ON EARTH NEEDS TO HAVE
A CANDY FLAVOR. I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL MEMBERS. I THANK
YOU SENATOR HELLO. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THIS BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR MITCHELL. PASSED
SENATORS THAT YOU PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONE BEFORE YOU
CAST YOUR VOTE SO WE HAVE A
CLEAR RECORD OF YOUR VOTE. A
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I AND I MALES. HI NIELSEN
AYE GONZALEZ HI. GONZALEZ I
GROW. ROVE KNOW HER TARA HI THE
TITLE AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE. EIGHT HOURS ONE
NOW THIS BILL IS OUT EIGHT ONE.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK
COLLEAGUES. RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM SO
AGAIN I NUMBER TWOS ON CONSENT
IT'S. ALTHOUGH. CHECK HERE.
OKAY PART FOR ME GOING MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR SINCE I
NUMBER THREE IS MINE AND THEY
ALWAYS GO AT THE END SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE BY CENTER
WIENER I THOUGHT I THINK I SEE
HIM IN THE ROOM IT'S USUALLY
HARD TO MISS SOME. YES THERE
OKAY. SO. WHAT WAS IT ABOUT THE
DUGGAR YES THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
MYDOCTOR THANK YOU YEAH AND-
YEAH SO WELCOME AND- PLEASE
BEGIN YOUR- PRESENTATION ON SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. GREAT I THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN THIS BILL
AND I WANNA. FIRST START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR- AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON THIS
BILL- TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE- WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED. AMENDMENTS
AND WE ALSO INDICATED WITH
REMOVING BUT A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION ARE FROM THE BILL. I
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY DEEP
APPRECIATION. FOR THE HARD WORK
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS
INCLUDING. A HEALTH ACCESS THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE BILL WHETHER THEY SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSE. BY CALLING SENATE
BILL A FIFTY FIVE. ON WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN ENSURING.
THAT CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS
PARITY WHEN IT COMES TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION CARE. TO
THE WE START TREATING. MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION TERROR AS
SOMEHOW DIFFERENT THAN PHYSICAL
CARE. WE KNOW THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS A CORE PART. OF HUMAN
HEALTH AND THAT. NOT COVERING
IT CREATE HUGE PROBLEMS WE HAVE
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IN THE STATE THAT
FOR EXIST TO COVER NINETEEN.
AND WE KNOW THAT CO IN NINETEEN
WILL MAKE A BAD SITUATION WORSE
AS PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA. ISOLATION
TO SPARE FROM THE ECONOMIC
COLLAPSE AND FROM ILLNESS AND
ALL OF THE CHANGES NEGATIVE
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING.
THAT WE KNOW WILL IMPACT
PEOPLE'S MENTAL HEALTH. AND
THAT WE KNOW WHAT IMPACT
ADDICTION IN FACT IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY I AM ALREADY
REGULARLY HEARING. ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN IN RECOVERY FOR
EXAMPLE FOR MATH. WHO WERE NOW
RELAPSING AND WE ARE WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS HAPPENING AND SO
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE HAS
JUST BECOME. EVEN MORE ACUTE.
AND SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE- DOES JUST A COUPLE OF
VERY BASIC THINGS. FIRST OF ALL
IT MAKES CLEAR. THAT INSURANCE
MUST COVER ALL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY ADDICTION AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE NOT JUST A SUBSET
THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY ACT FROM THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES WAS A BIG
STEP BUT IT'S LIMITED TO ONLY
NINE. MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
IT DOES NOT COVER SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. AND IT LEAVES OUT
SOME REALLY SIGNIFICANCE- THE
RELEASE A SIGNIFICANT- MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS INCLUDING
PTSD ANXIETY DISORDER OPIOID
USE DISORDER ALCOHOL USE
DISORDER STIMULANT DISORDER
BINGE EATING DISORDER AND MAJOR
NEUROCOGNITIVE DISORDER DUE TO
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY THOSE
ARE JUST EXAMPLES OF WHAT IT
LEAVES OUT. AND RIGHT NOW WE
KNOW THAT TOO MANY INSURANCE
COMPANIES WILL ONLY COVER
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE. IF YOU ARE ALREADY IN
CRISIS SO YOU'RE ALREADY ON
YOUR WAY TO THE SITE EMERGENCY
ROOM YOU MAY BE ALREADY LOST
YOUR JOB AND YOUR FAMILY AND
YOUR HOUSING. AND THEN YOU GET
TREATMENT ARE YOU ONLY GET A
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
UNTIL YOU STABILIZE. THIS IS
REALLY SIMILAR TO SAYING WE
KNOW YOU HAVE STAGE ONE CANCER.
IT'S NOT SERIOUS ENOUGH YET.
COME BACK AND SEE US FOR
COVERAGE WHEN YOU'RE AT STAGE
FOR WE WOULD LAUGH. THE
INSURANCE COMPANY OUT OF THE
ROOM NO ONE. WOULD ACCEPT THAT
AND YET WE HAVE BEEN ACCEPTING
A- WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION. AND IT'S NOT OKAY
AND WE SEE IT PLAY OUT ON OUR
STREETS. AND WE SEE IT PLAY OUT.
WHO HAVE HOUSING BUT ARE
SUFFERING QUIETLY. AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING QUIETLY.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THIS AND NOW
IS THE TIME TO DO IT. I WANT TO
KNOW THAT THE TO BOURBON
ALCESTE WAS VERY THOROUGH
APPROACH TO THIS BILL SHOWS
THAT THIS WILL HAVE A MINIMAL
IMPACT. ON PREMIUMS BUT IT WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE. AND WITH
RESPECT TO COVER NINETEEN I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY SAYING
REPORT CAME OUT THE OTHER DAY.
ESTIMATING THAT UP TO A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
AMERICANS. ARE GOING TO
EXPERIENCE WHAT WE CALL DEATH
FOR THE SPARE. DEATH BY SUICIDE
BY DRUG OVERDOSE. BY ALCOHOLISM
BECAUSE THE CURVE IN NINETEEN.
NORMALLY ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS DIE EACH
YEAR DUE TO DEATH BY THE SPARE.
THAT COULD ALMOST DOUBLE
BECAUSE THE CURVE IN NINETEEN
SO NOW IS THE TIME TO INTERVENE
TO STABILIZE THIS UNSTABLE
HEALTH SITUATION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MY WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY OUR DAVID LLOYD WHO'S A
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER WITH THE
KENNEDY FORM. AND NEAR A BEND
THAT- FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
US LIKE APPEAL MENTAL HEALTH
INSURANCE ADVOCACY LAW FIRM.
THEY'RE NOT PHYSICALLY WITH ME
BUT THEY'RE WORKING IN SPIRIT
AND HERE BY PHONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR SETTING THE
AMENDMENTS- LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT-
PRISON WILL TAKE IN THE THAT
THAT ORDER THATYOU MENTIONED-
FIRST- DAVID LLOYD- WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES IN
SUPPORT SO THAT'S FOR BOTH OF
YOU O KEEP THAT IN MIND WHEN
YOU TESTIFY SEE LEISURE. CO
PRESENTER SOMETIME TO SPEAK SO
WELCOME PLEASE PUT DOWN MISTER
LLOYD DAVID LLOYD ON TO THE- ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU CHAIR TOWN
NOT LISTED NIELSEN NUMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE UNDER THE WHY DID
CAN BE FORMED BY THE FORM
STEINBERG INSTITUTE OUR CREWS
TO BECOME A SPONSOR AND SB IN
FIFTY FIVE- BUT MAIN TESTIMONY
I'LL SEE THE BACKS OF MY TIME
TO ROMP AND DOT. IN ONLINE
PROTECT. THE QUESTION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. OUR THE SPRING
ANA MARIA THAT ON THE LINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU CHAIR
CAMBYSES CHAIR NIELSEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ROBIN DR AND I RESIDE
IN SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA.
LIKE A THERAPIST ATTORNEY AND
FOUNDER THANK YOU BUILDING A
LAW FIRM HELPING PATIENTS AND
FAMILIES CHALLENGE WRONGFUL
INSURED THE NILE NOT A HALL
THANK YOU TREATMENT. I'M A CO
LEAD COUNSEL FOR THE CERTIFIED
NATIONWIDE CLASSES WITH VERSUS
THE UNITED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I
AM TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF SB. EIGHT FIFTY FIVE BECAUSE
OF WHAT STABILIZE. CAROLYN LEE
AND MY AT THE END NEED FROM
HEALTH TREATMENT DID THE TRAUMA
LIKE THAT COVERED NOW. SB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE CLOSE MAJOR GAS IN
CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT. ALLOW
INSURERS TO DENY COVERAGE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WITH
IMPUNITY. ONLY THE CALIFORNIA
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT BY THE
ONLY NINE MENTAL ILLNESSES.
NATIONAL SERVICE. THE CHILD. IT
IS INDEFENSIBLE GIVEN THE
PREVALENCE OF STUFF YOU CAN
GIVE A DRAMATIC STRUCK WITH THE
ORDER AND COUNTLESS OTHER
TREATABLE DISORDER THAT THE
MINE. IT IS OFTEN INDEFENSIBLE
THE CALIFORNIA LAW LACK THE
UNIFORM DEFINITION OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY. AND DOES NOT MANDATE
THAT INSURANCE NAY COVERAGE
DETERMINATIONS BUT OUR CAN.
GENERALLY ACCEPTED STANDARDS OF
CARE. AS A RESULT OF THE
KEEPING HALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
ROUTINELY DENIED ACCESS TO
MEDICALLY NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. BY ENSURE THE
PRIORITIZE PROFITS OVER CARE.
SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE REQUIRES
INSURERS TO MAKE COVERAGE
DETERMINATION RETURNED TO
GENERALLY ACCEPTED STANDARDS
CARE. FOURTH BY NONPROFIT
CLINICAL SPECIALTY ASSOCIATIONS
RATHER THAN BY. INSURANCE HOME
COOKED GUIDELINE. WHEN PERSON
UNITE BEHAVIOR HEALTH THE CRIME
OF AN INSURER DEVELOPING THE
FACT COVERAGE GREAT. AMANDA
HAUGHTON THAT IS THE ORDER.
FOLLOWING A TEN DAY BENCH TRIAL
AGAINST THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST
HEALTH INSURER HEADQUARTERS
HEADQUARTERED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE UNITED STATES DISTRICT
COURT FOR THE NORTHERN DISTRICT
OF CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT YOU
BEACH A FINANCIAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. INFECTED GUIDELINE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS ON THAT
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS
INCLUDING THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN. WILL WRONGLY DENIED
OUTPATIENT INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT
AND RESIDENTIAL SERVICE THAT.
BASEMENT CRITERIA THAT WERE
INCONSISTENT WITH. GENERALLY
ACCEPTED STANDARDS OF CARE. IS
IT WILL TAKE A BUT NOT. YOU THE
AGE OF NOT ALLOW. THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. LIMIT COVERAGE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES BATES
AND ACTIVITY IN CRISIS
STANDARD. RATHER THAN
ACCOUNTING FOR DISEASE GRANITE
CITY AND ACCORDING GENUINE
RECOVERY. SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD THE
CONSUMERS AND TIRES PROVIDER
THERE REGULATORS CAN BE ASSURED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A REAL SHOT
AT RECOVERY. AND THAT ALL
INSURERS ARE PLAYING BY THE
SAME RULES. SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
WILL ALSO ENSURE ACCESS TO CARE
BASED ON STRICT ADHERENCE TO
GEOGRAPHIC COMPILING A
STANDARD. AND GUARANTEE THAT
WRONGFUL COVERAGE AND I'LL THE
REVIEWED BY COURT THE FRESH
RATHER THAN THROUGH THE LAND
THAT I'M DUE DEFERENCE. PLEASE
WRAP UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU PERFECT. ALL RIGHT-
SO FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
I DO I MENTION THAT WE HAVE A
TERRACE CITRON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAMS FOR. JUST
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
REGARDING THE TO BERMAN NOW
SAYS- SO WITH THAT- AT THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- OF.
THIS BILL. AND EIGHT FIVE FIVE
HERE AND- THIS. ROOM OKAY EN
ROUTE FORTY TWO THREE SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE ON TO ORDER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY. OKAY SEEING
NONE WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE SO WE WILL
NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS- LEADS
TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE- PROMPT
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT. OF
SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE. CERTAINLY
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
PLACE YOURSELF INTO THAT Q.
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF. ONLY A
LOT SECURING A ONE MOMENT PLACE
OKAY AND BLOW LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. LOOKS LIKE THAT ONE
IS NO LONGER IN A TWO ONE LEAD
TO TOTAL NUMBER PLEASE. ON A
MOMENT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT. OLOGY IS.
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE QUEUING UP
THAT THEY'RE JUMPING AROUND ON
ME ONE MOMENT. ONE TO TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND- HI MY NAME IS
TYLER MEDIUM WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE SUPPORT THIS THOUGH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNIG MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN SO PLAN
ON TOP OF THAT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT ONE
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO REGISTER OUR
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
TO LINE AT TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN TO ONE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE- THE CO SPONSOR OF IN
THE EIGHT FIVE FIVE WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT THE CHAIR AND
SENATOR WIENER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP TO MODERNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S PARITY ACT. AND
PREVENT TRAGEDIES LIKE THOSE IN
PLEASE EXCLUSION- IT DIES AWAY
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU YES
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATIONS
IMPOSITION APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY BE SELF
MUTED YOU ARE OPEN. WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ONE NEXT WANTING
TO IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR
ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AND GAVE THE ADS
HERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR ONE THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MICHAEL SO TO ON
BEHALF- THE NATIONAL UNION OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
REPRESENTS HOURS DAILY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN VALENCIA
REPRESENTING L. KERMES- A
GLOBAL LEADER IN MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN TWO TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOANNA
O'DONNELL. I AM BUT ACCESS AND
ALSO AN EDUCATOR WITH THAT
AWFUL CONSUMER IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU. TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
TO ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JOSEPHINE
FIGARO ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE A LOT IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT BY FIVE.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE TWO THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AUDIBLE CHAIR
MEMBERS SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. KIM. THANK YOU LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX TWO TWO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AN HONORABLE MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATINUM
VISORS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS NAMI CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. HE. GOOD
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS AMANDA
LEVY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU YOU. NINE TO THIRTY
FOUR TWO THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CURED MEMBERS HER
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE TWO TWO FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PINE TO TWENTY FIVE.
YOU'LL CITY NO CESSATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CONTRACT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR YOU CAN
COMMISSION. SHALL BE HVAC IN
SUPPORT AND AN EIGHT EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX TWO
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN TWO THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS PREFERRED DOCTOR ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
INSIDIOUS SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT. YEAH. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE TWO THREE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO NARROW IT
TO THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT. OKAY
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CRAIG PULLED HER FROM
THE KILLING HEALTH AND STRONG
SUPPORT. GIVE. THANK YOU LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE TWO
FOUR ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DIANA DOUGLAS
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACT OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
AB T. Q. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO ONE FOUR
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
FOUR TWO PLEASE CHECK FOR MUTE.
NO RESPONSE AND THAT DOES
CONCLUDE ALL THOSE FOR IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME CAN JUST
THIRD CHECK ONCE AGAIN BE SURE
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANKS AGAIN ONE OF
THEM ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT.
AND YES WE DO HAVE A FEW MORE
NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR ONE
TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE TWO FOUR. LET'S TRY LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE TO
FOUR THREE. IT MAY APPEAR THAT
WE'VE HAD A FEW STRINGS OF
PEOPLE ARE- THAT ARE
UNRESPONSIVE IT MAY BE A
TECHNICAL ISSUE ON OUR END
DOUBLE CHECK I HAVE ONE MORE
LINE I CAN TRY THAT IS LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE TWO FOUR
FIVE. GOOD MORNING CENTERS MY
NAME IS MICHAEL AM I AM AN
EXCELLENT CALIFORNIA INVESTOR
FROM CAL WAGES. AND I LIVE IN
TRUMPCARE COUNTY AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SD HI FI
THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE ENTIRE TO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MODERATOR. A LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE- BUT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
ALEX BEGAN AXES HERE IN THIS
ROOM- LAKE LOUISE US.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS I GUESS YOU SHOULD STILL
FORMALLY INTRODUCE YOURSELF AT
THE MICROPHONE HERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- NICK
LOUISE US WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS-
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE- MEMBERS A CAP
GENERALLY OPPOSES AT NEW
BENEFIT MANDY DEALS BECAUSE
EITHER INCREMENTALLY OR
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE THE COST
OF CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES EMPLOYERS- WELL IN OUR
VIEW- IT'S NEVER A GOOD TIME
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
PREMIUMS- IT IS AN ESPECIALLY
COMPLICATED AND CHALLENGING
TIME TO BE DURING SO AT THIS
TIME. I'M HEALTH PLANS- IN
ADDITION TO THE REST OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ARE WORKING
HARD TO MANAGE THE FALLOUT OF
THE CURRENT PANDEMIC INCLUDING
DEALING WITH RESPONSIBILITY OF
JUGGLING ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES
RELATED TO THE COST OF COVERED
NINETEEN. AND THE PENCIL TO MAN
FOR HEALTH SERVICES THAT HAVE
BEEN TEMPORARILY. MANY BILLS
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED WITHIN
THIS BROADER CONTEXT HAVING
SAID THIS- OUR PLANS ARE
DEDICATED TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE
AND- WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT MANY OF OUR PLANS ARE
DOING DOING A DURING THIS
CRISIS. AND I SHOULD POINT OUT
THE TEACHER BURKE ANALYSIS DOES.
CONFIRM THAT ALMOST 1100% OF
ENROLLEES RECEIVE COVERAGE IS
FOR THE SERVICES THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL ALREADY-
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LONG TERM CHALLENGES IN THIS
AREA AND WE MUST DEAL WITH THEM
COLLECTIVELY. ENSURING OUR
STATE HAS THE TOOLS AND PEOPLE
NEEDED TO DELIVER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS SERVICES IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY. OUR BIGGEST
OUTLINED HIS- OUTLINED IN THE
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
REPORTS FOR WHICH STATES THAT
BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT.
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE 50% FEWER
PSYCHIATRISTS. IN 20% FEWER
PSYCHOLOGISTS. ENGINE FAMILY
THERAPIST AND LICENSED
COUNSELORS AND SOCIAL WORKERS.
REGRET REGRETTABLY THIS BILL
DOES NOT MEET THIS PARTICULAR
CHALLENGE HEAD ON BUT TAKES THE
APPROACH OF MAKING THIS A
COVERAGE ISSUE ONLY. BY
MANDATING COVERAGE FOR ALL
THREE HUNDRED PLUS CONDITIONS
AND IN THE CURRENT EDITION OF
THE DSM. IN DOING O IN A WAY
THAT WE BELIEVE IN RAVEL'S OF
MANAGED CARE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS AN APPROACH THAT WE
FEEL IS FRAUGHT WITH AN
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES BY
DEFINING MEDICAL NECESSITY IN A
WAY THAT DIMINISHES PAYER
OVERSIGHT AND CHECKS AND
BALANCES. IT UNDERMINES
PROVIDER NETWORKS BY
DISCOURAGING PROVIDERS TO
CONTRACTING JOIN A HEALTH PLAN
THAT WORKS. AND SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL DOES SO BY REQUIRING
IMMEDIATE COVERAGE FOR OUT OF
NETWORK CARE VIA TIME CORTICAL
CONTINUITY OF CARE PROVISIONS
EXCEED THOSE FOUND IN LAW FOR
OTHER SERVICES THERE FOR
CREATING DISPARITY BETWEEN. THE
HEALTH OF THE REAL SERVICES
SIDE. AND IT IS ON THIS
PARTICULAR POINT DISCRETE
SERIES QUALITY OF CARE CONCERNS
PLANS ARE BARRED FROM TO TWELVE
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS FOR
INTERRUPTING A COURSE OF
TREATMENT. BY OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDERS FOR ALMOST ANY
REASON. THIS PLACE PATIENTS AT
RISK. AS IT WOULD LIVE IN A
PLANS ABILITY TO TRANSITION
INTO REALLY TO AN IN NETWORK.
FACILITY FOR WHICH THEY WOULD
RECEIVE THE PROTECTIONS GRANTED
UNDER CONTRACTS- INCLUDING
QUALITY OF CARE ASSURANCES. SO
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'LL
STOP THERE AND- JUST STATE THAT
CAP RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES BILL
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. AND I BELIEVE-
THERE'S ANOTHER WITNESS- FROM
THE OKAY HERE ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT YET PRESS AND YOUNG
FROM THE CAL CHAMBER I HAVE TO
THE DO YOU TOTAL WILL GET THREE
MINUTES AND NEXT KILEY USED ALL
THE- MOST OF THE TIME THAT- END
OF YOU GUYS COORDINATED OR NOT
BUT- I'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
GIVE A BRIEF STATEMENTS AND THE
OTHER A MINUTE IF THAT'S OKAY
CENTER. YEAH YOU CAN KEEP EVEN
FURTHER THAN THAT BUT PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PRESTON YOUNG FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. IN WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE I NEED TO FIRST
THANK SENATOR WIENER TO STAFF
FOR THE HARDWORKING OPEN LINES
OF COMMUNICATION WE ALL HAD
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO GET THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU SEE IN THE
BILL HERE TODAY SO MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU- AND THE
AMENDMENTS DO ASSUAGE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAD UNFORTUNATELY AS MR
LOUISE'S WAS ALLUDING TO THE
CONCERN THAT STILL EXISTS IS
THE FACT THAT THERE WILL BE
PREMIUM INCREASES DUE TO THE-
THE BENEFIT MANDATE. COVER
CALIFORNIA CAME OUT WITH AN
ANALYSIS INDICATING THAT
PREMIUMS NEXT YEAR MAY INCREASE
4240% IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO
THE ECHO THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IN EXPENSES- THEIR CURRENT
TWENTY TWENTY. WHEN YOU TAKE
THAT IN CONJUNCTION ITH THE
CURRENT BUSINESS CLIMATE WERE
BUSINESSES ARE DEALING WITH THE
DIFFICULTY IN UNCERTAINTY
KEEPING THEIR DOORS OPEN AND
THEN YOU'RE LAYERING ADDITIONAL
PREMIUMS AND EXPENSES ON TOP OF
INCREASING EXPENSES IN
PREMIUMS. IT IS A DIFFICULT-
STORM TO WEATHER SO- FOR THESE
REASONS I DO UNDERSTAND IT IS A
AN INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE TOPIC
AND ONE THAT HITS CLOSER TO
HOME THAN I WISH AND- I AM
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. EIGHTY THANK YOU FOR. ITS
FOR MUCH. OTHER WITNESS. AND
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO THOUGH
THREE. ST NINE LET'S MOVE TO
HEARING ROOM TWENTY FORTY. DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES THEIR
CASE SAYING NINE LET'S MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE- MODERATOR-
CAN YOU PLEASE- PROMPT PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SP
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. CERTAINLY IF
YOU ARE ON THE PHONE LINES AND
WISH TO VOICE YOUR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE A COUPLE
LETTER ALREADY INTO WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR ONE TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
TWO TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON THE UP AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTER IN ON TIME BUT WE ARE.
OPPOSE IN WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS CAP. THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE ONE FIVE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNOR OF
ARKANSAS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANY
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
IT IS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU ARE
NOT POSITION. AND THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL CHEWING UP AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO WITH THAT- LET'S
MOVE TO OUR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THEM BROWN'S.
pTHANK YOU- I WANNA JUST THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR SITTING I'M NOT
SITTING DOWN WITH BECAUSE WE
CANNOT BE HAD OUT THANK YOU
DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR
OUTLINING THE BILL AND HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION WITH ME ON MY
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
REMOVE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND I KNOW THAT- ONE
THING WE BOTH. STRONGLY AGREE
IS THAT THIS CALL MAY NINETEEN
AS HAVING. AN AMAZING-
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON ON OUR-
CALIFORNIANS AND- AND I KNOW
JUST BASED ON SOME RESEARCH
I'VE DONE EVEN ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE YOU KNOW THE UPTAKE
AND- THE STRESS AND THE
DEVASTATION AND DEATH. I THINK
YOU MENTIONED A HUNDRED. A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
AMERICANS WILL DIE A DEATH BY
DESPAIR AND- OUR COMMUNITIES
ALREADY SEEN THOSE OF FACTS AND
SO. I THINK THAT THESE ARE
DIFFERENT TIMES AND WE NEED TO
STEP UP AND MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MENTAL HEALTH. IS
YOU KNOW OUR PRIORITY AND SO I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
I HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE THE- THE OPPOSITION AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE WE
CAN COME UP WITH THAT. I'M
MORE- A COMPROMISE SOLUTION BUT
I WILL E SUPPORTING THE BILL
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK. OKAY
ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS SIR TADO.
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND- IN A FOR DOING THIS
THIS WORK- IT MEANS A LOT TO ME
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IN ON
THE VALLEY THAT TARA. REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH HIMSELF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS AND-
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND BUT LIKE TO BECOME A CO
AUTHORS WILL REVIVE THAT THANK
YOU CENTER. IS THERE A MOTION
THERE SEC BUT THE MONEY AFFECT
THEM OF THE BILL CEREMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I. WE STRUGGLE WE'VE
STRUGGLED FOR YEARS TO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH. DIAGNOSIS
TREATMENT. TREATED ON THE SAME
LEVEL AS ANY OTHER PHYSICAL
MALADY AND- THERE'S BEEN
RESISTANCE ALONG THE WAY AND-
IT'S PART OF THE TIGMA IN OUR
SOCIETY AS WELL SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. WON'T BE.
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I FOUND
SOME OF THE STATISTICS ALARMING
FIT. THESE CHALLENGES IN.
SEPARATIONS ARE EXACERBATED. BY
CODE NINETEEN. I THOUGHT YEAR
ANALOGY OF ASKING SOMEBODY
WITH- STAGE ONE CANCER TO WAIT.
UNTIL THEY HIT STAGE THREE OR
FOUR FOR TREATMENT TO BE A-
VERY COMPELLING. ANALOGY WE
WILL ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY IN THE
LONG RUN IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
IT THROUGH AN ECONOMIC LANDS. I
THINK THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
ALIGNS WITH THE HUMANITARIAN
AND MORAL. IMPERATIVE THAT WE-
OFFER TREATMENT- SUPPORT SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
SEASON. GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS CON MEN STRIKING ALL
RIGHT- SO SIR WINNER AT FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND ALSO- FOR
WORKING WITH- MY STAFF AND WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS STATE YOU. TAKEN SO
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO EARLY TO-
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
FOR THE COMMENTS WE WILL OF
COURSE TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS IS
GOING FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
OKAY THANK YOU SO- AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK UNDER CITRON FOR
STAYING ON THE LINE LOOKS LIKE
WE DO NEED TO CALL ON YOU- SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER TADO SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI. AND I
NIELSEN THOUGH. NIELSEN KNOW
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROW.
ACTUALLY YOU CAN ASK PEOPLE TO
TURN ON THE MICROPHONE ACOSTA.
THANK YOU BOTH KNOW HER TITLE.
YES I BY HER TITLE AYE LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE MONEY BY MONNING AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE. SEVEN TWO SO
YOUR BILL IS OUT SEVEN TO GIVE
AID TO COLLEGE ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
NINE THIRTY TWO ALSO BY CENTER
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON A SHORT TIME
TO USE THIS AS A SORT OF A TIME
SENSITIVE CODE RELATED BILL-
THAT WE PUT IN THE PRINT A FEW
WEEKS AGO- AFTER. ATTEMPTING TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ON AND SO OUR LGBTQ LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS DECIDED IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR THE BILL AND FRIENDS- DUE
TO CREATE SOME- TIME
SENSITIVITIES AND-YOU IN
YOURSELF REALLY WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH US. AND WE'RE
AND THE AMENDMENTS- THAT THE
THAT THE COMMITTEES PROPOSING-
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER BILL IN A
STRONGER BILL FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND SO WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT-
THE MOMENTS THAT I WANT TO.
LIVE I THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING TO BE AN AMAZING
ALLY TO THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY-
BECAUSE THIS BILL IS SOMETHING
A BILL THAT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BE- INTRODUCING. OR
CONSIDERING. ON THE FACT THAT
THE- OF CALIFORNIA. AND ITS
COUNTIES INCLUDING MY OWN
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO INCLUDING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TWENTY SOME
OF THE LARGEST. A COUNTY
THAT'LL LARGEST LGBTQ
POPULATIONS IN THE WORLD. ARE
NOT COLLECTING DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY AND HEALTH IMPACTS IN
OUR COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S WITH
RESPECT TO CODE MOST TIME
SENSITIVE BUT RISK REFER TO ALL
OTHER COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AS
WELL. AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
DATA IT SEEMS SOMETIMES IT GOES
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS A LITTLE
BORING IT'S NOT VERY SEXY. BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING WITH COVERT NINETEEN
RIGHT NOW. WHEN WE SEE. THAT
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
HAS CHEST APPALLING. DEATH
RATES. FROM THIS PANDEMIC. SO
DISPROPORTIONATE TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE WHEN WE SEE
pNEXT COMMUNITY THAT IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY IN THE MISSION WHERE
THEY TESTED THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
OVER THE COURSE OF A WEEK. AND
THE LIGHT MAX. PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE TESTS WERE UNDER FIFTY
PERCENT. BUT THE POSITIVE. FOR
THE TESTING WITH 95% MY NECK'S.
WE SEE THE HEALTH DISPARITIES
AMONG AGE GROUPS AMONG GENDERS
THE WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
INFECTED BECAUSE OF THEIR JOBS
THAT THEY HAVE MANY MORE LIKELY
TO GET VERY SICK. WELL WE KNOW
ALL THIS ONLY BECAUSE WE ASK
PEOPLE WHEN THEY GET TESTED
WHEN THEY GET TREATED. WHAT IS
YOUR RACE WHAT IS YOUR GENDER
WHAT IS YOUR AGE PEOPLE ARE
REQUIRED TO ANSWER BUT THEY
NORMALLY O. AND WE OBTAIN IN
VALUABLE DATA THAT HELPS US
FOCUS RESOURCES ON EDUCATION ON
AL REACH. WHEN HOW WE TREAT
PEOPLE. ON MAKING SURE THAT ONE
AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN SHOWS UP
IN THE HOSPITAL HE'S NOT
DISMISSED AS JUST COMPLAINING
THAT IT'S JUST AS REAL AS IF A
MIDDLE CLASS WHITE WOMAN SHOWS
UP. WE LEARN WE LEARN ABOUT THE
OVERCROWDING IN THE LIVE NEXT
COMMUNITY AND SO MANY OF OUR
CITIES. WE LEARN ABOUT THESE
RISKS FROM DATA AND YET AS A
SOCIETY WE HAVE. DECIDED NOT TO
COLLECT THIS DATA FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. BUT I WOULD SAY KNOW
WHERE THE GOVERNOR OF
PENNSYLVANIA JUST ANNOUNCED
TODAY THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
COLLECTING A- WE'RE NOT DOING
IT IN CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THAT
THE LGBT COMMUNITY HAS HIGH IN
HEALTH RISKS HIGHER RATES OF
HIV CERTAIN KINDS OF CANCER OF
SMOKING OF HOMELESSNESS THESE
ARE ALL RISK FACTORS FOR CODE
RED. WE NEED TO COLLECT THE
DATA THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
THAT CITY PH CHANGE ITS
DATABASE. TO DO THAT THAT THE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE DATABASES
WILL HAVE TO CHANGE IT AND THAT
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WILL HAVE
TO ASK FOR THIS VOLUNTARY
INFORMATION NO ONE WILL BE
FORCED TO ANSWER. AND THAT WE
WILL HAVE THE DATA FINALLY WE
HAVE DONE A MILLION TESTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE LOST AN ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITY. LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEXT MILLION TESTS. I
HAVE THIS INFORMATION I WOULD
LOVE FOR THE GOVERNOR TO ISSUE
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER AND DO THIS
IMMEDIATELY- WE NEED TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD AND THEN
ULTIMATELY EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
ALL COMMUNICABLE DISEASES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL AND
WITH ME DIGITAL AIR FLOW A
TESTIFIED. ARE A RICK SUPER
THE- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA OUR SPONSOR
AND THE MAN THE WALL THERE WITH
THE LGBTQ HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. NETWORK REMOVE THE
BILL. OKAY THANK YOU A AND YOU
SIR WINNER FOR WORKING WITH THE
STAFF AND TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
MODERATOR I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
HAVE- MISS THE REX'S A BURGER
AND I'VE BEGIN REMIND TO WE
HAVE TWO PEOPLE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT PROVIDING TESTIMONY OF
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES AGAIN
BE CONSCIOUS OF THE MARITIME
LEAVING FOR YOUR- OUR PART- SO
IS- RICK SUPER ON THE LINE HERE.
YES SIR HE BERMAN THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA ALL RIGHT SOMEONE TO
GO AHEAD BEGIN. YOU KNOW TODAY
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE TESTED FOR
CODE NINETEEN BUT WE WON'T KNOW
THE SEXUAL ORIENTATION OF THE
GENDER IDENTITY UP A SINGLE
ONE. WE WON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
AN OUTBREAK IN THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY IN ANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS OR ANYWHERE IN OUR
STATE AND WHEN THERE IS WE
WON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION TO
DETECT THOSE OUTBREAKS BUT YOU
WERE TECH TO HELP WITH LGBT Q.
PEOPLE. IN RECENT WEEKS THERE'S
BEEN IMPORTANT REPORTING ON
EIGHT HOW THE RATES WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND AMONG
OUR ELDERS AND LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES GENERALLY THREE OR
FOUR OR MORE TIMES HIGHER THAN
AMONG THE GENERAL PUBLIC. WE
ONLY KNOW ABOUT YOU CAN TAKE
STEPS REJECT ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE'RE
GATHERING AND REPORTING THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. BUT DESPITE
THE FACT THAT LGBT Q. PLUS
PEOPLE ALSO EXPERIENCE HEALTH
AND OTHER CONDITIONS THAT
SIGNALED EXTREME RISK FOR CODED
RELATED FATALITY. EVERY TO
SMOKING I'M UN COMPROMISE
HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY TODAY
OUR DATA IS NOT BEING COLLECTED
AT TESTING SITES ANYWHERE IN
THE STATE. I'M DISAPPOINTED
THAT WE EVEN NEED THIS BILL AND
THE LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE NEED TO
PLEAD WITH OUR GOVERNMENT ONCE
AGAIN TO TAKE VERY BASIC STEPS
TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH. IT LGBT
Q. PEOPLE ARE LEFT OUT OF THE
DATA THAT OUTBREAKS CAN'T BE
DETECTED AND DEATHS WON'T BE
PREVENTED THAT'S NOT CONJECTURE
IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW I LIVE TO THE AGE
CRISIS I HELD A HAND UP BY
FRIENDS SCORES OF THEM WHILE
THEY LAY DYING AS MIKE
GOVERNMENT BUT THE OTHER WAY.
BACK THEN ANY EIGHTY WE DIDN'T
HAVE AN LGBT Q. **** AS WE
DIDN'T HAVE DINNER WIENER
APPROACH GETTING AND DIDN'T
HAVE LONG I'D LIKE MINISTER
CHAIR AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE EITHER. WE DON'T
HAVE TO REACH THE END OF THIS
CRISIS DON'T LOOK BACK WITH
REGRET WE DON'T HAVE TO WONDER
WHY DIDN'T WE TAKE BASIC STEPS
TO PREVENT THE DEATHS OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE WHEN WE CUT. GOD KNOWS
I'VE BEEN TO TOO MANY FUNERALS
AND THAT TOO MANY GOOD BYE WELL
MY GOVERNMENT LOOK THE OTHER
WAY WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN
AGAIN NOT NOW NOT IN TWENTY
TWENTY NOT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BUT- THANK YOU THE
NEXT WITNESS IS AMANDA WALLNER
AND- YOU YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE.
AND FOUR SECONDS OKAY. GREAT
THANK YOU I'M GOOD MORNING MY
TO DEMAND- BONNER I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA TO
HELP YOU MEET YOUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK- DID.
THAT MAKE. IN WHICH OUR HEALTH
CARE DOWN QUITE INADEQUATE
SERVING LGBT Q. CALIFORNIANS
LONG BEFORE. LGBTQ ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE HEARD HE TURNED
AWAY BY HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
NIGHT NEEDED HEALTHCARE MORE
LIKELY DELAYED HEALTHCARE GO
WITHOUT FILLING A PRESCRIPTION
AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE A
REGULAR HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
AS A RESULT. PEOPLE ARE GREATER
RISK DURING THE TIME DO TO PRE
EXISTING HEALTH CONDITION.
EVERYTHING FROM INCREASED
WORKING RATE HIGHER RATE THE
BEACH IDEA IN CANCER WHICH CAN
COMPROMISE OUR ABILITY. SB NINE
THIRTY TWO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BETTER BY OUR
SPEECH TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS.
STRATEGY DATA COLLECTION IS
NEEDED SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW OLD YOU THINK
YOU COULD CALL ARE BEING
IMPACTED BUT FORGET NINETEEN.
OUR HOPE PROGRAM CAN PROVIDE
ARE QUITE REPORTING UNIFORMS
EXTRICATION GENDER IDENTITY
DATA. ARE OUT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CONDUCTED AN UNOFFICIAL AUDIT
DOCTRINE THIRTY DATA COLLECTION
AND DESPERATELY COUNTY THAN
PROGRAMMER AND FOUND A WIDE
VARIATION AND HOW THEY WERE
COLLECTING THAT INFORMATION AND
NO UNIFORM WAITING TO REPORT IT
YES YOU AND REPLICATE THE FIGHT
KNOWING. BUT JUST WRAPPING UP
YEAH DAVID KNOWING ABOUT
INCREASED RATE WE HAVE NO WAY
TO MEASURE THE CHORE IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIRTY EIGHT
AS NOT BEING UNIFORMLY
COLLECTED AND RECORDED DIRECTLY
DOWN- AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OR ADD.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT ALL SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN. THIS ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE WHO WISH TO. WE CAN
SUPPORT. CASEY NINE- LET'S MOVE
ON TO ROOM TO. HEARING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. I FORTY TWO WITH
THAT NOW. TWENTY FORTY DON'T
SEE ANYONE ALL RIGHT- THE
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THIRTY TWO. YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASUREYOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO LINE
THAT NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO SIX ZERO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- CREEK
FALLS FROM THE TOP OF A DELAY
HEALTH AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO THAT'S
TWO SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN THE DINNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONNECTING HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OUT THERE ON YOUR GREEN THE
LANGUAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE AT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JOSEPHINE FIGARO ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER THEY GOT
A LOT IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR TWO FIVE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS STUDENTS OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CRIMINAL LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT TWO TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI HOW ARE YOU THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE THANKS VERY MUCH SEE
NO ONE ELSE ON THE QUEUE- OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SAYING
NINE LET'S MOVE TO- HEARING
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THIRTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SAYING
NINE- MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE- PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES A CALL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE THIRTY TWO. MODERATOR.
OKAY SORRY THEY NEEDED ME ON
YOUR HANDS- WILL GO TO- IT'S
ONE IN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION WILL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE ONE SIX NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I CAN'T GET BURKE
WITH THE HOPE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. OUR
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
IS OPPOSED BUT THE AMENDMENTS
ACCEPTED IN COMMITTEE TODAY GO
A LONG WAY TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS I HAVE NOT YET HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO CHECK WITH MY
MEMBERS TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
REMAINING CONCERN. BUT LET ME
ASSURE YOU THAT WOULD BE
PLEASED WITH THE BILL NEVADA
COMMITTEE TODAY. THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE WHO WILL
WORK WORK ON THAT EL AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR THAT AND I
HOPE WE CAN. MOVE OUR
OPPOSITION VERY. I THANK YOU.
ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE ON THE PHONE
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY GUYS
CENTER GONZALEZ. SENATOR IENER
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS BILL TO VERY-
IMPORTANT BILL ESPECIALLY FOR
THE COMMUNITY- NOT ONLY
STANDARDIZING THE DATA BUT I
REMEMBER IN THE CITY COUNCIL IN
LONG BEACH BEING ABLE TO ADD
THAT QUESTION ON FOR THE
HOMELESS SENSES THAT WE WERE
TAKING AND HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS
TO BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
ADDITIONAL GANTS BECAUSE WE'VE
FOUND THE STATED TO BE SO
VALUABLE. WHAT I WOULD JUST
ALSO MENTION IN THE BILL IS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE A
CITY LIKE LONG BEACH HAS ITS
OWN HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE SPECIAL WITH
A LARGE POPULATION OF LGBT Q.
CALIFORNIANS THERE THAT THOSE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE ALSO
PART OF THIS- INFORMATION AND
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
DISAGGREGATED DATA BECAUSE WE
OBVIOUSLY NOW AS YOU KNOW
PREACHING TO THE CHOIR HERE.
THAT THE LGBT Q. COMMUNITIES
NOT UNIFORM IN THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND A BIT
MORE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS NOT YES SENATOR
MITCHELL. AGAIN JUST WANTED TO
RESTATE THAT I'D MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
JUST THANK. YOU SENATOR- AND
THE CAUCUS FOR BRING THE BIL
FORWARD. AND I THINK IT'S A
WAKE UP CALL TO ALL OF US IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. A WE'VE HEARD
FROM COUNTIES THAT ARE STILL
YOU KNOW. COLLECTING DATA BY
HAND ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS SO
CLEARLY IS AN AREA- BASED WHAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW AND SOME
OF THE DATA. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE DATA THAT YOU
SHARED THAT WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE
SURE WE MAKE PUBLIC INVESTMENT
IN AT THE- STATE LEVEL AND THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AROUND PREPARING
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
BE ABLE TO- DELIVER THIS DATA
TO HELP POLICYMAKERS. MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION.
SING OTHER NO OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THAT SIR WELL I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND- PLEASE HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS BILL AND-
HOPEFULLY WE'VE MADE IT BETTER.
AND SO CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN YES ARE YOU YOURSELF
HAVE MADE THE BILL BETTER AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT. I JUST TWO
BRIEF. COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL- I
WANT TO THANK GOD THE HEALTH
OFFICERS FOR WORKING WITH US WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM- AND ALSO A PROPOSED BY
CENTER GONZALEZ IS COMMON. OUR
GOAL WITH THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE COVER ALL OUR BASES. WE
KNOW THAT THE STATE SET UP THE
STRUCTURE WITH A STATEWIDE.
DATABASE AND REPORTING. THEY'RE
ALSO COUNTIES THAT ARE NOT PART
OF THE STATE DATABASE THAT'S LA
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES IN
PARTICULAR. OTHER COUNTIES LIKE
MY OWN. USE THE STATE DATABASE
AND ALSO HAVE A COUNTY
DATABASE. ON DEREK COUNTIES
WHERE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
ENTER DATA INTO THE DATABASE
DIRECTLY. IN OTHER COUNTIES
ONLY THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
ENTERS THE DATA SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT PROVIDERS.
ARE COLLECTING THE DATA WHEN
THEY'RE ALREADY COLLECTING
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. THAT TO THE
EXTENT THE COUNTIES HAVE A ROLE
THAT THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO
ENTER THE DATA IF IT DOES FLOW
THROUGH THEM SO YOU DON'T HAVE
COUNTY TO SAY. WE'LL DO REYES
DATA BUT WE DON'T WANT TO DO OF
THE TWO THAT A- AND THEN OF
COURSE AT THE STATE DOES WHAT
IT NEEDS TO DO WE THINK OF THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL.
LIKELY DOES ALL THAT. BUT AS I
DISCUSSED WITH THE CHAIR
YESTERDAY WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH. THE HEALTH
OFFICERS TO FIGURE OUT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE COVERING THE
FIELD AND- CLICK THE IF WE NEED
ANY. FIREMEN IT'S GOING DOWN
THE ROAD. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH. OUR GOVERNOR NEW SON AND
WITH DOCTOR ANGEL FROM C. P. H.
R. THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN A-
LONG TERM AMAZING ALLIED OUR
COMMUNITY WE'VE SPOKEN IN
DIRECTLY. HE GOT TO TALK TO
ANGEL GOT TO- WE WANT TO SEE
THINGS MOVE A NEW FASTER- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK VERY
COLLABORATIVELY. WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL. I THANK YOU
CENTER WINNERS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGAIN REMINDER TO
EVERY SENATOR PLEASE TURN ON.
YOUR MICROPHONE CASTER BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HAN HI AM
FINE MEALS HI NIELSEN AYE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW I GROW
BY HER TADO HI- TOTAL AYE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE MONEY NINE MONEY IN AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE. NINE YOUR
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO UNANIMOUS
THANK YOUR CALLING SECURITY
EXPECTED US FROM OKAY- SO THE
NEXT BILL WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
AND I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE OF HOW
WE TRY TO LINE UP OR WITNESSES
AND SO FORTH WILL BE- CENTER
MONIES PHIL SO I KNOW NORMALLY
WE USUALLY DO I KNOW SIR
JACKSON'S WAITING IN THE WINGS
AND SHE'S NOT A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT I BUT GIVEN THE
WAY WERE LINING UP WITNESSES
WILL MOVE NEXT TO- PHONE NUMBER
SIX SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN BY
CENTER MINING I JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF MOVEMENT AND- IN
THE ROOM AS WELL WILL ASK THE
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE 2% FROM.
THE FROM THERE'S THEY'RE
SITTING- SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE CONSTANTLY MOVING BACK
AND THREE WHITE TO SELL WITH
THE SIR MONEY. THANK YOU MISTER.
AND MEMBER. I'D LIKE TO START
BIKES THE CEERS MM AND IT ALSO
LIKE TO THINK TERRY BOWDEN FOR
ALL OF HER HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL ALONG WITH THE CHAIR IN
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. MEMBERS AS
THE WORLD RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS ACCESS
TO PROVIDERS AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE IS NOW MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER. AT THE SAME
TIME THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS CREATED ENORMOUS FINANCIAL
STRAINS ON BOTH HOSPITALS AND
PHYSICIANS. MAKING THESE
PROVIDERS SUSCEPTIBLE TO AND
PERHAPS AMENABLE TO
CONSOLIDATION ATTEMPTS BY LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AND PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT CONSOLIDATION
AFFILIATION ACQUISITION MERGER
OR ANY OTHER SPECIFIC ECONOMIC
OR BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
HOWEVER EXISTING LAW PROVIDES
LITTLE OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION AND MARK
TO MARKET PRACTICES OF FOR
PROFIT ENTITIES. LEFT LARGELY
UNCHECKED HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO GROW AND HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO UTILIZE ABUSE OF
MARKET PRACTICES THAT CAN DRIVE
UP PRICES IN REDUCE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OVERSIGHT OF
ACQUISITION OF MERGERS
INVOLVING NONPROFIT ENTITIES IN
MY DISTRICT I'VE HAD HOSPITAL
ACQUISITIONS INVOLVING BOTH
SECTORS. THE NONPROFIT
ACQUISITION UNDER THE REVIEW OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL GUARANTEED
CONTINUED OPERATION OF
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES AND
OTHER SERVICES OF IMPORTANCE TO
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. IN
ANOTHER PART OF MY DISTRICT A
PRIVATE HOSPITAL SERVING A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WAS
ACQUIRED BY A HEDGE FUND A
GROUP WITH NO REVIEW BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND NO
COMMITMENTS TO MAINTAIN A LEVEL
OF BASIC SERVICES TO THE
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY. SB NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS TO SUBMIT A
WRITTEN NOTIFICATION TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR NOW AND IF
LEAGUE ASIAN AND OR ACT.
BETWEEN HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN
ANY OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITY
OR PROVIDER THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD CONSENT OR DENY
THE AFFILIATION OR ACQUISITION
BASED ON TWO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FACTORS FIRST WHETHER
THE TRANSACTION WOULD INCREASE
CARE COORDINATION AND OR
AFFORDABILITY OF CARE TO AN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. AND
SECOND WHETHER THE TRANSACTION
IS SUBSTANTIALLY LIKELY TO
RESULT IN ANTI COMPETITIVE OF
X. THAT AT WELL A IN ANY OF THE
BENEFITS. IF THE ACQUISITION OR
AFFILIATION DOES NOT MEET
EITHER OF THESE REQUIREMENTS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MAY DENY
THE TRANSACTION. AT THIS TIME
WE ESTIMATE ONLY THIRTEEN LARGE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS WOULD FALL
UNDER THIS REVIEW PROCESS. THIS
ANALYSIS COULD CHANGE
ADDITIONALLY SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN WOULD DECLARE THAT HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS THAT EXERCISE
SUBSTANTIAL MARKET POWER ME
KNIGHTON GAUGE IN BEHAVIOR THAT
HAS A SIGNIFICANT LIKELIHOOD OF
ANTI COMPETITIVE IMPACTS. ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR SIR TO
FIND TO INCLUDE INCREASING
MARKET PRICES DIMINISHING
QUALITY OF CARE REDUCING CHOICE
INCREASING THE TOTAL COST OF
CARE OR DIMINISHING ACCESS TO
OR AVAILABILITY OF HOSPITAL OR
NON HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
SEVEN ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
HEALTH POLICY ADVISORY BOARD
LED BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
BOARD WOULD EVALUATE AND
ANALYZE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
MARKETS IN UPON REQUEST BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE BOARD
REVIEW HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
REQUEST FOR AFFILIATION OR
ACQUISITION. THE BOARD WOULD
INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES OF A
BROAD CROSS SECTION OF
BUSINESSES MEDICAL COMMUNITY
AND OTHER REPRESENTATIVES. THE
BOARD MIR'S MANY OF THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY OFFICE THAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. IF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL MOVES
FORWARD I AM OPEN TO REMOVING
THE ADVISORY BOARD PROVISIONS
FROM S. B. NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
MEMBERS AS COVERT NINETEEN
IMPACTS ARE FORCING
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN INSURERS
RESPONSIBLE OVERSIGHT OF THE
GROWTH OF LARGE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS AND THEIR IMPACT ON THE
HEALTH CARE MARKET. MEMBERS I'D
NOW LIKE TO PRESENT WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- JENNY
PHILIP SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL FIVE YEAR
PESETA. EMILIO BERNINI DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE ANTI
TRUST SECTION A AND WE HAVE
BETH CAPELL WITH HEALTH ACCESS
ON THE PHONE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS A
RESOURCE I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YEAR
PESETA. FOR HIS PARTNERSHIP AND
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO TRY TO FIND. A
PATHWAY THAT ACHIEVES OUR
SHARED OBJECTIVE OF PROTECTING
PATIENT AND CONSUMER SAFE
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE IN
BETTER OUTCOMES IN WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD DEFER TO
MY WITNESSES BOTH OF WHOM I
THINK ARE. IN THE ROOM AND THEN
OUR PHONE RESOURCE WITH MISS
COMPEL SHOULD ANYONE HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR HER. I THINK WE
HAVE- CHENEY PHILLIPS READY TO
TESTIFY THROUGH THE CHAIR OKAY
THANK THANK YOU- CENTER MINING
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THE THANK
YOU FOR. ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
AND I KNOW THE WORK YOUR STAFF
AS WELL TWENTY JOHN STAFF HAS
DOES TO WORK THIS OUT SO WELL
LET'S GO HEAD TAKE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IT'S THREE MINUTES
TOTAL FOR ALL THE WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND AND MISC HELLO THE
BETH CAPELL IS BASICALLY FOR
QUESTIONS SO- YOU CAN FIGURE
OUT. THIS PHILIPSON. MISTER
BENNETT HOW YOU DIVIDE THE TIME
BETWEEN THE TWO OKAY THANK YOU
SO PLEASE PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES. AND PRESENTED
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU AS THE
MORNING TO AND CAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JENNY PHILLIPS AND I AM
THE SPECIAL TURNER FOR HOBBY
ERR BUT SERRA AND WHO IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
I'M HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
AMELIA VERNIS THAT WHO IS A
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ANTI
TRUST EXPERT BUT NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT IS PARAMOUNT TO
STRENGTHEN ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE. AND QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. TO PROTECT PATIENT
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTH CARE SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
FOCUSES ON TO. ISSUES AND IT
FIRST IT REQUIRES LARGE HELP
THERE'S CARE SYSTEMS PRIVATE
EQUITY GROUPS AND HEDGE FUNDS
TO OBTAIN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S APPROVAL BEFORE
ACQUIRING OR AFFILIATING WITH
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS. TO BE
APPROVED THESE TRANSACTIONS
NEED TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
WILL ACTUALLY BENEFIT PATIENTS
IN THE FORM OF HIGHER QUALITY
LOWER COSTS OR INCREASE ACCESS
AND UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
THE SECOND PART OF THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT LARGE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS FROM ENGAGING IN
BEHAVIOR THAT WOULD RAISE
MARKET PRICES SINCE DIMINISH
QUALITY REDUCE CHOICE INCREASE
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE OR
DIMINISH ACCESS TO SERVICES.
EVEN BEFORE THIS COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR IN THE
HEALTHCARE MARKET WAS A GROWING
CONCERN BECAUSE OF THESE LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A STUDY FOUND THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF PHYSICIANS AND
PRACTICES OWNED BY HOSPITALS
INCREASED FROM ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. IN TWENTY TEN TO
MORE THAN 40% IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THIS RESULTED IN AN
ESTIMATED 12% INCREASE IN
PREMIUMS FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS EXPERIENCED
AND TAKING ON THESE LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AND HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
IMPACT ON HEALTH CARE MARKET.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
UNION AND EMPLACEMENT A TRUST
ENTERED INTO A PRELIMINARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OVER
LITIGATION OVER SUTTER HEALTH.
THE LAWSUIT ALLEGED THAT SORT
OF HEALTH IT OBTAINS
SUBSTANTIAL MARKET POWER AND
CERTAIN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
MARKETS TO ACQUISITIONS OF NOT
ONLY HOSPITALS BUT ALSO
PHYSICIAN GROUPS AND SURGICAL
CENTERS. THE SETTLEMENT
INCLUDED A GROUNDBREAKING FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IN FEES AND BROAD
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF TO RE BALANCE
COMPETITION IN THE MARKET. SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN BUILT ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S EXPERIENCE
AND SUTTER HEALTH IN THE SUTTER
HEALTH CASE BY GRANTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THE AUTHORITY
TO REVIEW THESE TYPES OF
TRANSACTIONS ON THE FRONT END
THAT LEAD TO THE CREATION OF
THESE LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
ALSO. PROHIBIT THESE PREDATORY
MARKET PRACTICES BY LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND MY COLLEAGUE AND I ARE HERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY FROM YOUR
TEAM OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SO- IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE AND- THIS FROM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN FAVOR OF
SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN. THREE NINE
LET'S MOVE TO HEARING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT SCENE NINE. LET'S MOVE
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT TO A
MODERATOR FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THAT IS
OUR PUBLIC COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN. IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE LINE UP A
PUBLIC COME IN AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TEN. TO
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
EXCEPT L. FOR L. TAXES SINCE
CORD INJURED IN TURN QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. IF YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT TWO
ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HERE'S A TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF
THE KILL WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
IS SERRA FLOCKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GET A
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE
ZERO FOUR. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND EIGHTY AS HERE ON
BEHALF OF YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA I
APOLOGIZE THAT OUR SUPPORT IS
NOT REFLECTED ON THE ANNOUNCED
IT BUT- YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA IF
THE STOCK. SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ASSISTANCE LAURIE
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
TWO SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS DADDY GROW ALL THAT
YEAH HE W. I. THIRTY POUNDS ONE
SUPPORTED APOLOGIES FOR NOT
GETTING A LETTER SUPPORTING
TIME THAT'S AFFECTED IN AND OUT
BUT WE GET THE PART THAT OUT.
THANKS THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JESSE
RIGHT NOW WE CAL BOYS THEM BACK.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU YOU. ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINES HAS A MESSAGE
OF SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SEEING NO
FURTHER IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR- NOW
WILL TAKE A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE
AND- FORTY TWO A THREE. OKAY A
I THOUGHT SOUTHERN ALL RIGHT
NOW IS THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OKAY SCENE NINE-
MODERATORS THERE- ANYONE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALEX HAWTHORN ON
THE. THE IN THE- THE ROOM THAT
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. HELLO JUST
MOVED TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
CONRAD. ONLY LOOKING FOR
SPECIFICALLY SET OF FROM
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
I THOUGHT THEY WERE GONNA LIGHT
HAD SOMEONE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. BUT THERE IS A
SOMEONE SPECIFICALLY THEN WE
CAN JUST GENERALLY OPEN FOR
COMP PUBLIC COMMENT THAT POINT.
VERY GOOD NE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT THEN IS
YOUR- AT THIS TIME. WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN THAT'S ONE FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DOCTOR PAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALEX HAWTHORN AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
LISTEN TO THIS BILL- I THINK
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE PUBLIC NOW THAT THE
ABILITY OF HOSPITALS TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS AND WE CHANGE WE FACE
MANY CHALLENGES AHEAD. TO SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES. WOULD NINETEEN
HAS PUT TREMENDOUS STRAIN ON
HOSPITAL FINANCES BUT WE STILL
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING ON.
A EXISTING PIECES OF
LEGISLATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
ADMINISTRATION- THE LEGISLATURE
TO FOCUS ON THAT HEALTHCARE
SPENDING IN COSTS WITH THE
GOAL. OF LOWERING GROWTH AND
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE OPPOSITE
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY WAS
MENTIONED. WE REMAIN COMMITTED
TO THAT THAT BILL AND LEANING
INTO THAT PROCESS-
UNFORTUNATELY ESPYS NINE SEVEN
SEVEN IS NOT THE CORRECT
APPROACH. AND IS A DEEPLY
FLAWED PROPOSAL FOR SEVERAL
REASONS. THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR SOME TIME
HAS HAD QUITE BROAD AUTHORITY-
OVER HOSPITAL PURCHASES THAT
LARGE ASSET TRANSFERS- EXISTING
PROCESS IS FLAWED. THE GOAL
SHOULD ALWAYS BE TO PRESERVE
ACCESS TO CARE- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROCESS IN
PLACE CURRENTLY HAS RESULTED IN
A HOSPITAL CLOSURES. MATTER
SEVERAL SEVERAL RECENT EXAMPLES
OF THAT. THE BILL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TODAY- DOUBLES DOWN
ON THAT PROCESS IT IS
INCREDIBLY BROAD IT SWEEPS AND
COUNTLESS ARRANGEMENTS THAT ARE
COMMON AMONGST A HOSPITALS
PHYSICIANS. LABORATORIES AND
OTHERS I'M WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT LARGE SCALE MERGERS AND
ACQUISITIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT
VERY GRANULAR AND DAY TO DAY. A
COMMON ARRANGEMENTS AMONGST
PROVIDERS- PEACE ARRANGEMENTS
EXIST FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
FINANCIAL EFFICIENCY EXPAND
ACCESS TO SERVICES CLINICAL
IMMIGRATION. BUT ACCORDING TO
PATIENT CARE- BOLSTERED SUPPORT
FOR OUR WORKFORCE FOR NURSES
AND PHYSICIANS. THE BILL
PROVIDES VIRTUALLY NO APPEAL
PROCESS FOR HOSPITALS OR OTHER
PROVIDERS THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT
THERE'S NO GUARD RAILS THERE'S
NO CLEAR DEFINITIONS ARE
PARAMETERS. IT IT BESTOWS
ABSOLUTE AN ARBITRARY
DISCRETION- ON THE OFFICE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND IT
ALSO CREATES A GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT SYSTEM FOR MY
MEMBERS. FINALLY FUNDAMENTALLY
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES IS
CONSOLIDATES TREMENDOUS POWER-
INTO ONE PLACE AND THIS IS A
PLACE THAT WILL HAVE POWER OVER
EACH OF YOUR COMMUNITIES FOR
YOUR HOSPITALS FOR YOUR
POSITIONS- FOR YOUR POSITION
GROUPS IN LABORATORIES- IT'S A
VERY POLITICAL PROCESS IN OUR
EXPERIENCE. IN A MINUTE IT IS
CERTAIN TO HALT THE WORK BEING
DONE BY HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
AND REDUCE CRITIC. TASK THAT.
JUST FINAL NOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS WE DID RECEIVE THOSE
LATE LAST NIGHT- OUR INITIAL
READ OF THEM IS THE ONLY
ADDRESS- A VERY SMALL PART OF
THIS WHICH WAS SMALL PRACTICES-
OTHER THAN THAT WE- WE DO THEM
IS LARGELY TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S- OPENED THE-
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN AND- ASKED
THAT PEOPLE STATE THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION WHICH I PRESUME SHOULD
BE OPPOSED SUCH AS THE
OPPOSITION TIME. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK OUT
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHT TWO ZERO EIGHT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
MERRY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
TWO SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHORT ON BEHALF OF EACH THE
PRIVATE DENTAL ACCESS COMMUNITY
HOSPITALS ARE SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS ADVENTIST HEALTH N
LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO SEVEN
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MEGAN LOW FOR
ON BEHALF OF TE UNITED
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN TWO ONE SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE
BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN TWO SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KELLY HEAD ON BEHALF OF
SUTTER HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE TWO SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JANUARY JANUARY WITH A DIRTY
LAW GROUP ON BEHALF OF KINDRED
HEALTHCARE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO TWO FIVE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AMY TO READ
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ANYMORE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HOW WILL I
KNOW IF TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT
TWO ZERO EIGHT TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY APOLOGIES AND MEMBERS
AND SHARE THIS IS MARTIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
POPULOUS POSITION I STATED
THAT. LONG FORMER EMPLOYER MY
PRIOR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH THERE YES- PLEASE
COME TO MY FROM NAME ORANGE
ASIAN POSITION THANK YOU
PRESSED IN YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE- MEMBERS COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. THE BILL OKAY
THERE'S A MOTION FROM SIR LEYVA
THAT'S A RUBIO. THANK YOU- WELL
FIRST FOUR THANK MISTER MONEY
BECAUSE I AND I DEFENDER STAND-
AS I AM READING- THE AG'S
LETTER IN TERMS OF. WHAT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AS YOU KNOW
THEY NEED TO ENSURE THAT-
DURING THIS TIME WERE SMALL
FACILITIES ARE VULNERABLE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THESE PREDATORY
AT YOU KNOW HEDGE FUND DOOR
EQUITY GROUPS TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW SO I KNOW THAT TEMPORE INTO
HAVE SOME SAFEGUARDS IN THAT
REGARD- AND- I HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS RATHER I
MEAN ASK YOU ALL KNOW WE GOT.
MONEY AMENDMENTS LAST NIGHT
AFTER I WENT TO SEE WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO READ I'M UP DID
NOT AND SO THERE'S A LITTLE-
CONCERN OF NOT HAVING
UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE THE NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO- I HAVE OVER A
DOZEN FACILITIES AND COMMUNITY.
AND TOM AND TOM IT IN THAT ARM
THAT THE BILL MAKES IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT- WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
SMALLER FACILITIES THAT ALREADY
STRUGGLING RGHT BUT I FEEL
LIKE THE SAME ARGUMENT CAN BE
DONE ON THE OTHER SIDE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW I'VE MET WITH ALL MY
MIGHT WRITERS AND MY- SECOND.
ANY STRUGGLING THEY HAVE
CONCERNS IN AND SO NOT QUITE
SURE WHAT THE ON IN IMPACT I TO
THIS FOR THE SEMI AREA IN I AM
ALWAYS CAN ABOUT JOB LOSS.
ACCESS TO CALL CARE IS THE THAT
REPRESENT. SOME OF THE MOST.
BANISHED AND SO FOR ME IT'S A
LITTLE THE END. QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE. AND I KNOW CLARA. SO I
WILL. READ WITH RED. BECAUSE
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT DOWN WITH ANYBODY TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL. SO AGAIN I
WILL- SUPPORTED BUT I
DEFINITELY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- I YOU KNOW I ALSO HEARD
THAT THIS IS BASED ON THE
SUTTER SITUATION AND- SOMETIMES
I FEEL THAT. SOME SITUATIONS
BECAUSE OTHERS TO DEAL WITH THE
BRUNT OF THE POLICY WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE INITIAL INTENT OF THE BILL.
BUT AGAIN IT'S A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS A LOT OF THINGS THAT I
NEED CLARIFICATION ON. I YOU
DID STATE THAT THIRTEEN
FACILITIES WILL FALL UNDER THIS
REVIEW. BUT THAT MIGHT CHANGE
SO YOU'RE NOT SURE AND SO AGAIN
A LOT OF UNKNOWNS RIGHT NOW FOR
ME SO I WILL SUPPORT WITH
RESERVATIONS AND HOPEFULLY. WE
CAN HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. SEEING NONE I
JUST CEREMONY I TO GET A WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND ALSO
WANTING TO ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE- IT I DO. WE WERE
NEGOTIATING TOLL FAIRLY LATE SO
HIGH MY APOLOGIES- FOR THE LATE
MEN MEN SO THEY BASICALLY DO-
TRY TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS
EIGHT AND DIED NAY NOTE THAT
THE OPPOSITION DID NOT FIND
THEM SUFFICIENT FOR THEM AND I
THINK THAT DESPITE ON THE
ONGOING DIALOGUE AND TERMS OF.
FIGURING OUT HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD- JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
SOME OF THE THINGS SO WE DID-
ASKS FOR A TIGHTER DEFINITION
OF FILIATION IN TERMS OF THE
NATURE OF WHAT TO RELATIONSHIPS
WOULD GO BE UNDER TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL SCRUTINY- WE'VE CREATED
MORE SPECIFIC DEFINITIONS FOR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE IN
TERMS OF- BASICALLY SHOWING
THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAVE BETTER
CLINICAL INTEGRATION AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF CARE SO
THERE'S MORE CERTAINTY FOR
STAYS FOR THE- PRESIDENT'S AS
TO WHAT. WILL QUALIFY SO WE
SPECIFIED SIMPLICITY-
GUIDELINES FROM FROM WIDELY
RECOGNIZED NATIONAL GROUPS- AND
THEN ALSO- WE ACTUALLY SAID ANY
TRANSACTION UNDER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR BELOW- THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ASSEMBLY REVIEW FOR
MARKET. FIRST SCREEN FOR
ESSENTIALLY MARKET FOR THAT
CONSOLIDATIONS ANOTHER TO WE'RE
TRYING AND DON'T FORGET THAT
ONE THE PARTIES INVOLVED IS
GOING TO BE A LARGE HELPS
PROTECT ONLY THIRTEEN FIVE AND
TWENTIES CALIFORNIA THE ONE
THREE A LARGE PARTY. THE OTHER
ONE THAT TURN THE OTHER NIGHT
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS THAT
SOME OF THEM ARE FOR COULD BE
FAIRLY SMALL BUT THERE ARE- IT
TRANSACTION PLEASE ON FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. I WOULD TO
MALL YEAH WE IS MORE THAN A
STATE OF MISSION THIS DO YOU.
OUR. JERRY JONES. QUICKLY LOOK
AT IN STATE THAT CHANGE THE
MARKET IS GOING TO LIKE THEY
COME IN OP THE MARK BECAUSE
THIS SERVICE. OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IF DOESN'T TRIGGER THE-
THEN THEY WOULD NOT RE IT SO IT
IT DOES THEN THEY CAN REVIEW
BECAUSE AGAIN DON'T WANT THE
OVER MARKETS. SO THAT'S A VERY
QUICK SUMMARY OF THE MAIN
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IT'S
ONE TO MENTION THOSE SO THAT
PEOPLE HAVE CERTAIN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE DID- I
KNOW PEOPLE THAT LATE AT NIGHT-
SO WITH THAT I THINK SEVEN
CONSULTED YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
OKAY ALL RIGHTS OPERATE- AND
THEN PERHAPS AND IT'S CENTER
MINING AT THAT SO- DID YOU WANT
ANSWERS AND RUBIO IS. DO THAT
IN THE COURSE MY THOSE OF THIS.
OKAY TIME A MEDIUM ONE OTHER
COMMENT. LIKE SO AGAIN I THINK
THAT IS. A BILL TO CHALLENGE
WITH VOICE WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH TERMS OF OUR
HEALTH CARE CLASSES THE TENSION
BETWEEN. WE WANT PEOPLE
ORGANIZED TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
QUALITY OF CARE. RIGHT WE KNOW
THAT- SOLO PRACTICES SOMETIMES
DON'T HAVE TO CAPITAL AND SO
FORTH. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ONLY
CONSOLIDATED. THEY ALSO IT'S
ARE DEVELOPING AT TOO MUCH
MARKET POWER WHICH TRIES OF
COST WITHOUT GETTING INCREASING
VALUE SO. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS REALLY TO TRY TO- HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL EVALUATE FOR
LARGE SYSTEMS. BECAUSE ONLY
PRICE WHEN THE PARTIES HAVE TO
BE ALERT SYSTEM. THAT THEY
ENGAGE IN SOME SORT OF
ACQUISITION OR A PHILLY LC
KNITTING AFFILIATION. THAT DAY.
THAT THERE IS SOME REVIEW TO BE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST SIMPLY
CONSOLIDATING THE MARKET EVEN
MORE AND WE'RE NOT GETTING SOME
BENEFIT OUT OF THAT. NOW WE CAN
ARGUE ABOUT WHETHER THE AGES
ARE RIGHT BY YOU DO THAT AND
OTHER TYPES OF. THINGS THAT'S
WHAT THE ROLE THE H. AS-
BECAUSE DUE TO TAKE STE. AND
SO. THAT IS. WHAT THAT SO BAD
BECAUSE OF THAT. YEAH SUPPORT
THE BILL. HAS I THINK THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. AND WANT TO CONTINUE
TO DIALOGUE AGAIN PRE. THE V.
THE PIECE OF. BACK AND FORTH
WITH WITH THE KEYS OFFICE IN
REGARDS BILL SO WITH THAT.
MONEY LIKE. YEAH AND AGAIN I
THINK MR CHEERING. I DO NOT
DRESS SENATOR RUBIO IT'S QUITE.
IN IN THE OF MY CLOTHES. BUT I
DO ALSO. I THANK YOU IN YOUR
STATE. TWENTY AND I THINK WE'VE
LANDED IN A GOOD SPOT IN ANY DO
A FOR MY- COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING. TO WORK ON THIS SO
A COUPLE OF PRINCIPLES THAT I
THINK ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS AND
THOSE OF SOME OF THOSE THAT
THAT WEIGHED IN. WITH CONCERNS
ARE OPPOSITION AND I KNOW A
SENATOR RUBIO YOU WERE JUST.
RAISING QUESTIONS FOR YOUR
DISTRICT IN THE PEOPLE YOU
REPRESENT. FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THIS BILL IS NOT DESIGNED TO
EMPOWER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
PROHIBIT BLOCK- OR GET IN THE
WAY OF. AFFILIATIONS
ACQUISITIONS MERGERS THAT WILL
BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITIES. THE
LENS IS HOW OUR PATIENTS AND
CONSUMERS GOING TO BE. IMPACTED
SO FOR ME I REPRESENT A NUMBER
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
GAVE THE EXAMPLE. OF ONE IT WAS
IN THE WATSONVILLE AREA
PURCHASE BY HEDGE FUND PRIVATE
TO PRIVATE. THE AG HAD NO
JURISDICTION NOBILITY FOR
OVERSIGHT A COMMUNITY HEALTH
TRUSTS SOUGHT TO ENGAGE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO HAD TO
RESPOND I'M SORRY. THIS IS
PRIVATE TO PRIVATE I DO NOT
HAVE JURISDICTION. THE CONCERN
THE ONLY EMERGENCY ROOM IN THAT
COMMUNITY THE NEXT CLOSEST AN
HOUR AWAY. THE FEAR OF IF THEY
CLOSE THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHAT
HAPPENS SO. WELL WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY THE AG DOES OVER
NONPROFIT. AND TRANSACTIONS
BETWEEN THE NONPROFIT HOSPITAL
IN A PRIVATE OR NON-PROFIT
BUYER. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PROTECT A CONTINUATION OF
SERVICES. THE BACKDROP OF THIS.
THE WASHINGTON POST REPORTS
THAT WE'VE GONE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IN THIS COUNTRY
FROM ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOSPITAL BEDS. TO UNDER NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. IT'S ALMOST
HAVE THE NUMBER OF HOSPITAL
BEDS DURING CORONAVIRUS WE SEE
THIS NEED TO EXPAND OUR
CAPACITY THAT'S ONE OF THE-
EMERGING THE RESPONSES GOVERNOR
TO SOME PRIORITIZE. BUILDING
ARKHAM. BUT ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES IS IT SHRUNK AND IT
SHRUNK BECAUSE- SOME OF THESE
ENTITIES HAVE BEEN RUNNING FOR
CORPORATE EFFICIENCY
SHAREHOLDER PROFIT BUT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY TRANSLATE
TO THE GOOD OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THE GOOD OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REMAINS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF SOME OF THESE BUSINESS
TRANSACTIONS AGAIN IF IT PASSES
THAT LITMUS TEST. THERE'S NO
CATCH THIS BILL ALSO EMPOWERS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO WAIVE.
CHECK EARLY IN RURAL AREAS BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HE AND
HIS STAFF IN REVIEWING A
PROPOSED ACQUISITION MERGER
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE THEY CAN
DO A QUICK LITMUS TEST AND IF
IT MEETS THE BENEFIT OF THE
COMMUNITY THEY CAN WAVE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT IS
AVAILABLE UNDER THIS BILL BUT
NOT MANDATORY THERE IS A WAIVER
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT. THE
PUBLIC INTEREST THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THE COMMUNITY HEALTH.
FROM I DID WANT TO MENTION- NOT
IN TESTIMONY TODAY BUT HE A
LATE LETTER FROM THE PACIFIC
BUSINESS GROUP OF HEALTH IN
SUPPORT. THEY REPRESENT
EMPLOYERS WHO BY AND LARGE
HEALTH PLANS TO PROTECT
EMPLOYEES OF BUSINESSES OF
BUSINESS ENTITIES SO THIS BILL
INTERESTING THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER. BUSINESS OWNERS. AND
UNION REPRESENTATIVES THEIR
COMMONALITY IS THAT THEY BOTH
ARE BUYING PRODUCT FOR THEIR
MEMBERS BE THE UNION MEMBERS OR
BUSINESS EMPLOYEES OF THE
BUSINESS SECTOR. SO YOU WILL
THOSE LETTERS WERE SENT TO YOUR
OFFICES THROUGH THE CHAIR IN
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT IT'S
ONE THAT ON THE RECORD TO
SUPPORT PACIFIC BUSINESS. OF
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE SEEK IS TO
EXPAND QUALITY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ONE OF THE I THINK
STRONG AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY
THE CHAIR IS LOOKING NOT JUST
AT. MARKET DOMINATION FROM AN
ECONOMIC POINT OF VIEW. LOOKING
AT ONE OF THE TESTS BEING NOT
JUST ACCESS AT THE FRONT END.
BUT OUTCOMES ARE THE DESIGNS OF
HEALTH CONSOLIDATION GOING ONLY
NEED TO BETTER OUTCOMES AND
PART OF THAT WOULD BE SUPPORT
MAINTENANCE A PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. ACCESS TO
VACCINATIONS TO PREVENTIVE
HEALTH TO DRUG TREATMENT
ALCOHOL TREATMENT THINGS. LAN
TO BETTER LONG TERM OUTCOMES
FOR THAT COMMUNITY SO THAT WAS
ONE OF THE I THINK STRONG
PUBLIC HEALTH DEFINITIONS THAT
WAS SUGGESTED. THROUGH THE
CHAIR IN HIS STEP SO AGAIN- I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IN PARTICULARLY EXACERBATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN SOME OF ARGUED
WILL BECAUSE OF IT NINETEEN IN
THE SECOND EMIC PRESSURES. WE
REALLY DIDN'T BE PUTTING IN
MORE OVERSIGHT MORE REGULATION
BECAUSE THESE ENTITIES ARE
STRUGGLING. THIS IS EXACTLY
NGUYEN LARGE HEAD COACH FUNDS
WILL THAT DEEP POCKETS WILL
COME IN A TAKE IT OF A LOCAL
RURAL CLINICS STRUCK AS THE
ROAD. THIS BILL DOESN'T
PROHIBIT IT IT JUST SAYS IF
YOU'RE GONNA DO IT ARE WE GONNA
REDUCE SERVICE THAT UNDERSERVED.
WHERE WE GONNA MEAN SIR THIS
CREW TO ASSIST SO THAT'S THE
CHECK TO I HAVE EVERY. IN THE
CHAIR IN IN- FOREVER. GENERAL
IT WILL MISSION THE BILL BUT IS
NOT OVER SOME IN AND FOR
EMPOWER SEAT THE GENERAL TO THE
SAME JURIST HE HAS IS OVER NON
MERGERS TO EXTEND TO FOR MERGE
IN FACT IT'S IN THE FOR A RE.
THAT I FEAR THERE ARE GREATER
ABUSES TAKING PLACE SO WITH
THAT- I WOULD ASK RESPECTFULLY
FREE YEAR HI VOTE IN AGAIN
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS SUPPORT
OF BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
I KNEW THAT IT WAS CLOTHES SO
WE HAVE OR BILLS WE HAVE BEEN
IN HOUR BUT I WILL. CENTER
GROVE ONE EIGHT. FOR MORE FOR
QUESTION YOU ANSWER CHARITY
APOLOGIZE I A JUST LIKE TO US
ALL A COUPLE QUESTIONS THE BILL
ALLOW FOR RULES TO APPLY FOR IF
IT WOULD IMPROVING IS THERE A
CRIED I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
LOOKING AT YOU IS THERE A
CRITERIA THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS GOING TO USE- ON
DETERMINE ACTS IS ANY IT AG AND
NUYS THE REQUEST THEIR APPEAL
PROCESS FOR LOCAL SPITTLE FOR
ONE IN TWO. OR THREE SPECIFIC
GUIDELINES THAT SHOULD THE
CURRENT REVIEW A PROCESSING
CONDITIONS PLACED ON THE
HOSPITAL AND DOES THE FINANCIAL
CONDITION OF THE HOSPITAL HAVE
TO BE CONSIDERED AND IT WILL
LET ME TAKE THE FIRST AND THEN
AGAIN IN THE PHONE LADY'S
OFFICE IF THEY WANNA ADD ON TO
THE CHAIR BUT FIRST OF ALL THE
ON THE ON. THE H. AT. OF THE-
ACT. MERGER IT IS IN IF A QUICK
REVIEW SHOWS THAT OING TO
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY. HE HAS
THE AUTHORITY. TO APPROVE AND
WAIVE ANY. NO LONGER TERM
PROCESS OF EVALUATION ETCETERA.
THE SECOND PART OF YOUR
QUESTION I THINK WENT TO REMIND
ME- ON THE CONDITIONS PLACED ON
THE HOSPITAL IS THERE A CURRENT
OR THE GUIDELINES IN STATUTE SO
THAT WE CAN SEE THE CONDITIONS
ARE REPLACED ON THE HOSPITAL.
WHEN YOU SEE CONDITIONS PLACED
ON A HOSPITAL SO A HOSPITAL
THAT SEEKING TO EXPAND ITS
OPERATION THROUGH ACQUISITION-
OF OTHER HOSPITALS OR CLINICS.
THE TWO CRITERIA THEIR EXPLICIT
IN THE BILL LOOK TO.
MAINTENANCE ARE IMPROVEMENT OF
THE QUALITY OF HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY. AND IN ORDINANCE
MARKET CONTROL LEADING TO ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRACTICE THAT
THAT'S THOSE ARE THE TWO
EXPLICIT CRITERIA THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BE HELD TO
TERMS OF APPEAL RIGHTS. THE
BILL IS EXPLICIT IN SAYING IF
AN APPLICANT IS DISSATISFIED
WITH THE DECISION OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THEY CAN FILE
FOR A WRIT OF MANDATE THEY HAVE
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT KEPT
WITHIN THE CONTROL OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVING THAT
INVOICE. THEY CAN SEEK REVIEW
IN A COURT OF LAW THROUGH A
WRIT OF MANDATE RATES ARE THE
FASTEST PROCESS TO DO PROCESS
IN PORT SOME SO WE BASICALLY IN.
GRIEVED APPLICANT TAX TO THE
COURT TO IT OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THE THEATER GENERAL CAN BE. IN
THAT. HE IS NO LONGER THE MAKER
THANK YOU SIR AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE OKAY THANK YOU YEAH.
BUT THERE A MOTION ON THIS BILL.
HELLO ALL RIGHT RESERVED AUTO
DID GET IN FIRST STEP ALRIGHT
SO IT'S THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER HER TADO-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND AGAIN REMIND GIVEN TURN ON
THE MICROPHONE TO. CAN I. AM I
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN KNOW
GONZALEZ. AND SALAS SIDE GROW
NO GROWTH NO FURTADO I. THOUGHT
OH BY LEYVA I. LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL BY SO I'M- NINE ON IN
I. HI I. OKAY THE BILLS OUT TWO
HIS. OKAY NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
EIGHT SAYS LA TEN BY SIR TOM SO
YOUR GO AHEAD AND PRESENT. FROM
YOUR SEAT. I GUESS QUICKTIME
CHECK IT'S ELEVEN THIRTY SIX WE
HAVE A HARD STOP AT TWELVE
THIRTY AND- SO TRIED IF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO START BY SETTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED EACH EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS. SB LOT TEN PREMEDICAL
PATHWAY PROGRAM A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
SCHOOLS ARE TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS WHO LIVE IN
RECENT IN REGIONS THAT ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND IS TO
ATTACK MEDICAL. FOR MEDICINES
COLLEGE PRO WAS THE THESE WHO
WISH TO PER. TRAINING AND ENTER
MEDICAL SCHOOL AND- IN REGIONS
SUCH AS A CENTRAL VALLEY. THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND IMPERIAL
VALLEY COMMUNITIES ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING THE PAINS OF
PROVIDER SHORTAGES LACK OF
NETWORK ADEQUACY AND POOR
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THIS AND WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE NOW. FOR
THE UCSF HELP FOR CENTER
CALIFORNIA'S PREDICTED SEE
SHORTAGE OF OVER FOUR THOUSAND
PRIMARY. CARE PHYSICIANS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND MY DISTRICT
PATIENTS FACE LONGER THAN
AVERAGE TIMES TO SEE A
PHYSICIAN OR EXTENSIVE TIME TO
TRAVEL TO THE NEAREST HOSPITAL
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE. CALLERS
PROGRAM WOULD HELP SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OF YOUNG
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND WE
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS AN
INTEGRAL. COMPONENT TO ENABLING
THEM TO HELP STOP OR LIMIT THE
NEXT PANDEMIC. TODAY I HAVE
WITH ME ARIANNA MORALIS
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE COALITION.
OKAY THANK. THANK YOU CENTER
TADO OF THIS YES WE HAVE A-
ARIANNA MOUSE WELCOME BUT THIS
IS SUPPORT. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ARIANNA
MARLINS AND I SERVE ON THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE COALITION
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION'S
BACKBONE AGENCY THE MARKETS
FOSTER EDUCATION INSTITUTE.
BEFORE ENSURE MORE IN THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM OR CMS P. I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE THAT AS YOU MAY KNOW
DOCTOR NANCE MENDOZA AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AT KERN
COLIN BAKERSFIELD WAS
UNFORTUNATELY TO JOIN TODAY TO
SHARE HER STORY IN PERCENT. ON
THE THIRTY TO GET SIR
SACRAMENTO WELL IN OUR CURRENT.
FOR LETTER SUPPORT A ROUGH HAND
OF THE IN OF THE- OF COLOR IN
THE LARGER. WERE MEDICAL SAYS
HAS NO BEEN TO SOME WITH AND
THAT THE QUALITY CARE. SO I HER
BEHALF EXCERPT HER LETTERS SO I
WOULD LIKE TO WITH YOU. PROVIDE
ANOTHER PERSON. THAT OF THE
STUDENT IN CHILD SUCH PAY.
BELIEVE EXAM. THE DIRECTOR. OF
THE ARK OF CAL MEDICINE THAT
MOTIVATED THE CREATION OF THIS
PROGRAM. SHE SAYS I AM PROUD TO
SAY. I AM THE PRODUCT OF HARD
WORKING FARMERS OF FARMWORKERS
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ALTHOUGH
THEY COULD NEVER HELP ME WITH
MY HOMEWORK AS THEY DO NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH. MY PARENTS
WHOLEHEARTEDLY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACHIEVING A
HIGHER EDUCATION. ALTHOUGH I
LOVE THE SCIENCES BECOMING A
DOCTOR WAS SOMETHING I DREAMED
BUT I THOUGHT I COULD CHEAT. A
LITTLE TIMES I'M TO ADOPT
OFFICE. WE'RE SORRY IN THOSE TO
LOOK LIKE ME. DOCTOR MENDOZA
GOES ON TO HOW IT WAS THROUGH
SHEER LUCK AND PERSEVERANCE AND
QUOTE THAT SHE PURSUED OR
STUDIES THAT CSU BAKERSFIELD
AND THEN THE UCLA DAVID GEFFEN
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. AS DOCTOR
MENDOZA DESCRIBE SHE WAS
LACKING COMMON NINETEEN IS LAID
BARE THE NEED FOR PHYSICIANS OF
COLOR WE CAN NO LONGER RELY ON
LUCK TO BUILD THE WORK FORCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES NEED. OUR
COALITION CALIFORNIA AND IS A
DIVERSE GROUP OF PROFESSIONALS
FROM ACROSS OUR THREE SEGMENTS
OF OUR EDUCATION MEDICAL
SCHOOLS THE HEALTH INDUSTRY
ADVOCATES AND STATEWIDE
PHILANTHROPIC INSTITUTIONS MANY
HAVE DEVOTED DECADES TO LEADING
THEIR PIPELINE PROGRAMS WITH A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED MODELS.
FOR SUCCESS YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE
DR. BUILDING ON THE- OF THESE
MY SEEM A IS THE TO PROPOSE A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
STRATEGY TO TAP THE DIVERSITY
AND TALENTOF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THEIR STUDENTS.
AND BRING INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
SEGMENTS INSPECTORS TO INSPECT
INTENTIONALLY COLLABORATE TO
IMPROVE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. WHILE
MOST LOCAL PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
SUPPLEMENTING THE RESOURCES ARE
INSTITUTIONS ALREADY OFFER CMS
PIECES ONLINE TO HELP
INSTITUTIONS LEVERAGE AND
BETTER A LINE EXISTING
RESOURCES AND IMPLEMENT
MEASURED SYSTEMIC PRACTICE AND
POLICY CHANGES. CURRENT
RESEARCH HAS DOCUMENTED THE
BARRIERS THAT MINORITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE
AND TRANSFER RETENTION AND
ACADEMIC PREPARATION TOWARDS
MEDICAL SCHOOL SAM S. B.
METRICS WILL BE ALIGNED ALONG
THESE KING'S MILESTONES. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SAY
NONE ARE THERE WITNESSES
SUPPORT AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NONE OF WITH PLEASE TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN TEN. MODERATOR
YOUR THE PHONE LINES YES IF YOU
ON THE PHONE LINES IN IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN THAT'S TWO EIGHT
SEVEN. NOW WHICH ARE THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A FEW MORE
CHEWING UP HERE ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND. EIGHTY SIX SIX
TWO EIGHT SIX. GOOD MORNING
GERRY MEMBERS THERE ARE A
COUPLE BEHALF OF UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THAT'S TWO
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JANE BRINGER CO FOUNDER AN
EDUCATOR DEEP TALK WE SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TEN. YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
RECALL LINE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THAT'S TWO EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE DOCTOR
QUITE IS AN EX. I'M CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE COALITION
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TEN. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PEOPLE ON THE LINE FROM
SUPPORT. NO ONE ELSE INTO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION DENNY
THIS IS A POSITION HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SAY NINE
LET'S. A MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NONE ALEX MOVED TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
OF PLEASE PROP PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN TEN.
LADIES AND JOHN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY VOICE THAT BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. WELL OKAY THERE'S A
MOTION- RIGHT YES CENTER MONEY.
JUST REAL QUICKLY I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AS YOU
ARTICULATE IN THE BILL SEEKS TO
IDENTIFY PROMOTING MORE
RESOURCES WE'VE HAD STATE
PROGRAMS THAT HELP WITH LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR STUDENTS WHO COME
TO AN UNDERSERVED AREA OUT OF
MEDICAL SCHOOL. BUT WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT THIS IS MOVING TO THE
FRONT END OF TRYING TO. CREATE
BETTER PATHWAYS SO I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORT AND WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE IS THE BILL MOVES
ALONG THANK YOU. THANK YOU US
AND RUBIO THANK YOU I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND- IF I
RECALL YEAH I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL. YOUR
DISTRICT AND BOMB SENATOR
HOLLINGS IS THERE WE HAD DIED
IN THIS AMP. ED I COMMIT ON
TRYING FIGURE OUT JUST AND WERE
I THINK WAS A FRESNO I'M ONE OF
THAT KEPT UP NOT OR IS NOT ONLY
RETURN P. TO STAND WORLD. BUT
ALSO AND EVERY I THINK WITNESS
SO EVER NOT THEY HAVE THE TO
SOMEONE THAT'LL LIKE THEM IN
THESE PROFESSIONS THAT THEY
WANT TO PURSUE AND SO. I WAS
REALLY INTO THIS. I AND- THE
MALL PHONE. HAS NO. SO I'M
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAYING
NINE ACERTAR THANK YOU FOR.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP CERTAINLY GET A
DRESSER WORKFORCE ISSUES IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL NEED TO
DO WITH LIKE CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOUOKAY THANK YOU
CENTER TADO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN
AMENDMENTS IT'S BEEN MOVED.
LEYVA SECRETARY WELL THE ROLE.
ONE HI AM I. NIELSEN
CONSOLIDATE REMIND PEOPLE TO
TURN ON THE MICROPHONE SO THE
CAT SERVICE FOR THE RECORD
ORRY BUT CAN YOU PLEASE
RESTART THE ROLE YEAH. PAN HI
AND I NIELSEN THOUGH NIELSEN
LOW GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I
GROW I. DROVE BY HER TADO I THE
TITLE AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL HI. SO I MONNING NINE
MONEY IN I RUBIO HI RUBIO BY.
EIGHT ONE CAN YOU BILLS OUT
EIGHT ONE YOUR RECORD THANK YOU
SURCHARGE RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON NOW TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB TWELVE A SEVEN THE SENATE
JACKSON WHO WILL BE JOINING US
ON. VIDEO THROUGH ZOOM AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE CENTER JACKSON-
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WAITING AWHILE.
THANK YOU I ALMOST FEEL LIKE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE HAVING.
HEARD ALL THE BILLS AND SO
FORTH SO I AM DELIGHTED TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT TO SB TWELVE AU
SEVEN TO YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AT THE TOP OF PAGE
SEVEN I IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. SO SB TWELVE AU SEVEN
ENSURES THAT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HIGHLY VULNERABLE
PERSONS RESIDING IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES DURING POWER
OUTAGES FIRST FROM VIRGIN. A
NAP DISASTER OR A SAFE POWER
SHOT TWICE KNOWN AS PS PS IS.
ON ANY OF THOSE ADVANCE. BY
REQUIRING A MINIMUM OF NINETY
SIX HOURS WORTH OF BACKUP POWER
TO THE CRITICAL SYSTEMS UPON
WHICH THESE. FACILITIES AND
THESE RESIDENTS FOR. RELY THIS.
REQUIREMENT ARE CALIFORNIA
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS HAVE
ALWAYS FACED SERIOUS RISKS FROM
DISASTER RELATED EMERGENCIES
SUCH AS EARTHQUAKES FLOODS MUD
SLIDES AND WILDFIRES IN
ADDITION TO THE MOST CURRENT
ARE CRISIS RELATED THIS COVERT
NINETEEN. HOWEVER TODAY THE
DANGERS THEY FACE ARE MAGNIFIED
EXPONENTIALLY DUE TO MASSIVE
BLACKOUTS TRIGGERED BY P.
JEANNIE AND OTHER UTILITY
COMPANIES. THAT ARE DOING WORK
ON THEIR VERY IS TO QUIT.
OSTENSIBLY TO PREVENT WILDFIRES
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
DOZENS OF CALIFORNIA NURSING
HOMES LOST POWER DURING THOSE
P. S. P. S. PERIODS AND
SOMETIMES FOR DAYS AS OF THESE
COMPANIES THE UTILITIES- WENT
THROUGH THIS P. S. P. S.
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS-
ENERGY. URGENT PATIENT- AND A
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT THIS
DISTRICTS TO. SENIORS ARE
INCREASE IN REAL THREATS TO THE
HEALTH WELL BE. TO THE- AT THE
FACILITIES TO THEIR OWN OXYGEN
TANKS FOR EXAMPLE TO THE
MEDICINES THAT THEY RELY UPON
TO SURVIVE AS WELL AS PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH HEAT
TEMPERATURES BEING EXTREME AND
WHICH HAVE SUCH ADVERSE IMPACTS
ON THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION.
NOW THIS RISK OF COURSE HAS
BEEN BROUGHT INTO EVEN SHARPER
RELIEF AS A RESULT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN VIRUS THAT IS
SWEEPING OUR COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD- EARLY OF COURSE WE KNOW
ARE AMONG THE MOST AT RISK OF
INFECTION AND DEATH AND THAT
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND NURSING
HOME. IN CAL WE HAVE ALREADY
THEIR LIVES THE PANDEMIC AT
LEAST OF IF NOT MORE DANCE
CHAMPION AND THESE THE NORTH
NURSING FACILITIES. WELL THE
FOCUS HERE IS THE USUAL POWER
AT THOSE FACILITIES AND WITHOUT
POWER THE RESIDENTS ARE A GREAT
RISK MOST RESIDENTS ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY VULNERABLE MANY
ARE COMPLETELY DEPENDENT ON
THEIR CARE GIVERS TO THEIR POOR
HEALTH AND SOME RELY AS TO
MENTION ON ELECTRICAL POWER DUE
TO. JUST JUST SAY A. BASED FREE
TRADE BETTER AND MEDICAL THIS
IS WITHOUT CAN HAVE DEADLY CALM
FOR THESE REST AND- THE REASON
FOR THIS BILL IS A WAS A GREAT
CAN TO ME AND I KNOW TOO MANY
THAT FEW OF OUR STATES NURSING
HOMES ARE PREPARED TO KEEP
THEIR RESIDENT SHAPE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND EXTENDED POWER
OUTAGES ACCORDING TO FEDERAL
REPORTS AND ANECDOTALLY I THINK
ALL WITHIN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN. OUR AS A
RESULT THE VARIOUS FIRES AS THE
PSP A SHOT OFF- BECAME A MORE
AND MORE IN THE FOR AND OF
COURSE NOW WITH OUR COLD WITH
NINETEEN PRICES. CORD NUMBER OF.
NINETEEN FROM THE HEALTH HUMAN.
OFFICE ARE ON THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOUND THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ARE AT AN INCREASED
RISK OF INJURY OR DEATH DURING
EMERGENCIES. ALL OF THE NURSING
HOMES THAT IT EXAMINED IN HIGH
RISK AREAS OF THE STATE
REPEATEDLY VIOLATED CRITICAL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
STANDARDS. RATHER GO INTO GREAT
DETAIL. ON THAT I JUST WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT OUR
CURRENT STATE REGULATIONS. ONLY
REQUIRE NURSING FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE VERY LIMITED BACKUP
POWER FOR APPROXIMATELY SO UP
TO SIX. HOURS AND THIS IS
SIMPLY INSUFFICIENT SO THIS
WEEK'S. IS A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT CLIMATE OF EXTREME
WEATHER WILD FIRES AND POWER
OUTAGES TO SAY NOTHING OF THE
OTHER PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
OUR CURRENT PANDEMIC. SO SB
TWELVE AU SEVEN. INSTEAD
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TO HAVE
BACKUP POWER SYSTEMS THAT
MAINTAIN SAFE TEMPERATURES AND
POWER TO CRITICAL SYSTEMS FOR
RESIDENTIAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
FOR AT LEAST NINETY SIX HOURS
DURING ANY TYPE OF POWER
OUTAGE. THIS BILL WHY NINETY
SIX HOURS IT CONFORMS STATE
PRACTICES THE CURRENT FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS WHILE ALLOWING FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE EVENT THAT
MORE PROTECTIVE REGULATIONS OR
RULES ARE ADOPTED LATER BY
EITHER THE STATE OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. NOW WE KNOW THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
REDUCING A LOT OF. ITS
REGULATIONS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
HERE AND SO LONG AS THEY ARE IN
FACT TO BE IMPLEMENTED ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHICH WE BELIEVE
THEY ARE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE TO
CONFORM TO THOSE REGULATIONS.
AND KNOW THAT IT IS BEST FOR
NURSING HOME A NURSING FACILITY
RESIDENTS TO SHELTER IN PLACE
IMPOSSIBLE DURING ONE OF THESE
INCIDENTS. SO IF THAT IS THE
REASON WE KNOW IT TO BE TRUE
AND THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
PROTECT THESE PATIENTS. HAVE TO
THE SAFE AND. FOR GEN STAYS AND
OTHER SURE EXCUSE ME PROVIDE
THOSE ASSIGNED PART. SO I THINK
WITH ME TO ON THE LINE AT LEAST
ARE THE BILL'S CO SPONSORS
KAREN JONES DIRECTOR AND
PROGRAM MANAGER UP FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY AND
MICHAEL CONNORS ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES. FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM OKAY THANKS
SO MUCH SENATOR JACKSON'S SO-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE BRING-
KAREN JONES ON THE LINE. DO YOU
HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES
BETWEEN BOTH OF YOU IF YOU DO A
SHORTER OF BE APPRECIATED WE'RE
UP AGAINST TIME CAP. SO TURN
JONES. ALRIGHT THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KAREN JONES AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR  PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF SALAS
DISPOSE COUNTY. I'VE BEEN AN
OMBUDSMAN FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS
AND FOR THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS
I PARTNERED WITH STAINLESS BUT
PH<c.cyan>OUNTY HEALTH AGENCY. THE</c>
PLAN FOR EMERGENCIES THAT
AFFECT LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES THAT INCLUDES POWER
OUTAGES FIRES NUCLEAR EVENT AND
PANDEMICS I AM AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF OUR COUNTY EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR KEVIN
NINETEEN. BUT WE'VE LEARNED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHEN
HURRICANE KATRINA CHANGED
EVERYTHING FIRMER TO KEEP
ENDING CARE FACILITIES. A
PERFECT TO HAVE ATTY. TO
ALTERNATE POWER DURING OUTAGES
AND A SHELTER IN PLACE WHENEVER
POSSIBLE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWELVE ELDERLY
RESIDENTS DIE. DID HE STARTED
NURSING HOW MANY ARE THERE.
THIS WAS IN THE AFTERMATH OF
HURRICANE IRMA WHERE THE
FACILITY HAD LOST POWER IN THE
IN ATTEMPT NEAR ONE HUNDRED
EAST. SO THAT LAW POWER NO
CONTROL THE HEAT. LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA HAS WE ON NUMBER
PROVIDER START GETTING PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOW OFF THE TERM
OFF POWER IN LARGE PORTIONS THE
STATE. LEAVING CARE FACILITIES
AND THE MANY WHO ARE IN THE
DARK. THE CIVILITY IS A DID NOT
HAVE NINETY SIX HOURS OF
GENERATOR FUEL DIDN'T HAVE THE
MEANS TO PROVIDE SAFE MEDICINE
FOR TEMPERATURES FOR THE
RESIDENTS. PRESIDENT'S
SIGNATURE REQUIRED OXYGEN DID
NOT HAVE THE MEANS TO ACCESS TO
THE POWER THAT THEIR
CONCENTRATORS NEEDED. AND
THANKS FOR NOT. ADEQUATE SUPPLY.
ACT POWERS THAT SET OFF TO
CONTINUE FOR THE NEXT NINE
YEARS. SB TWELVE AU SEVEN WELL
I'M SURE THAT NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR THE
MOST BASIC OF RESIDENT NEEDS
DURING AN OUTAGE. AND SOMETHING
THAT WAS NOT CONSIDERED WHEN
THE BILL WAS FIRST PROPOSED IS
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT-
EVEN DURING A POWER OUTAGE CARE
FACILITY RESIDENTS DO NOT GO TO
A COMMUNITY SHELTER. WHERE THE
RISK OF EXPOSURE SIX OF IT
NINETEEN WILL BE MUCH GREATER.
THE FACILITIES NEED TO SHELTER
IN PLACE AND WE NEED THEM TO DO
THAT WITH. THE THAT THE
RESIDENTS NEED. BILL WILL
PROVIDE FOR THAT THAT MINITOWER
AND IT WILL TAKE CARE OF WHAT
THOSE RESIDENTS NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING ON-
MICHAEL CONNORS SO YOU HAVE
FIFTY SIX SEONDS. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE HUNDREDS
OF CALIFORNIA OUT TO GET SOME
PERSONAL FOR. THANK YOU FOR
SENATOR JACKSON'S GREAT
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS ARE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS AS
SENATOR JACKSON POINTED OUT
OVER ONE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
NURSING ALL RESIDENTS DONE SO
FAR. THANK YOU. THE UNSAFE
CONDITIONS IN TOO MANY
FACILITIES WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
STABILIZE NOW AROUND THE CORNER
WHEN WILD TURKEY SEASON BRINGS.
A NEW ROUND OF DANGEROUS POWER
BLACKOUTS. THAT DON'T. ORDER TO
PUT THE CHURCH NOT. OF ALL
THESE IN CALIFORNIA. TWELVE
SERVING AS A VERY SOME BILL
IT'S A STRONG MESSAGE TO
NURSING HOME UP. TO COMPLY
EXISTING FEDERAL ARE BACKED UP.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO THOSE. SOME PEOPLE
LIVING IN NURSING HOMES WILL
DIE IF WE DON'T. YOU TO PASS
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OF THREE. SAY NONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO TELECONFERENCE LINE
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO
TEST IT TO PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE OH SEVEN.
YES IF YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT TWO TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS HIGH ON
THE YEAH- I LEFT. THAT THE
SOCIAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE TWO NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CAN STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND
FORTIFICATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE END OF THE
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY TWO NINE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL SABINO
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LITTLE
LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY THREE
TWO NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DR FIRM MEMBERS DIALED
DISABILITY LIKE CALIFORNIA.
BILL THANK YOU. AND THEY'RE NO
MORE INTUITIVE. ALRIGHT LET'S
MOVE N THEN TO OPPOSITION- IS
THERE ANY PLACE TO FIND
OPPOSITION INTO YOUR ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SAY NOT- LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THREE
ONE TESTIFYING OPPOSITION. OKAY
LET'S MOVE TO THE ACT CUT
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE OF SEVEN. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION HERE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN THAT'S TWO NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER SLATER ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SITUATION HEALTH
FACILITIES- WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER NINE HUNDRED COLLECTIVELY
THEN THE STATE. I'M WE DO
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORK ON
THIS BILL AND BELIEVE THAT THE
COMEDIAN THAT MEANT THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TAKING TODAY ARE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS STILL SOME. LACK
OF CLARITY TO EXACTLY WHAT THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
RELATED TO. THEIR BACKUP POWER
SYSTEMS DURING A POWER OUTAGE-
WE- DO AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
MINUTES IMPORTANT FIRST BILL
THERE'S USUALLY TO BE PREPARED
FOR POWER OUTAGES. AND TO HAVE
APPROPRIATE IN PLACE- SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THOUGH THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE. NOT COST.
SO ARE IN LINE WITH FEDERAL WE-
AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF EACH
SPECIFIC BUILDING AND THEIR
RESIDENT THANK THE IN THOSE
BUILDINGS SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
ALLEN CLEAR SIGN. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH. WE DOES.
REGULATE THOSE THE HOT YOU KNOW
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE WILL AND
LASTLY IS THAT NURSE FACILITY
HAVE THE NECESSARY SUPPORT
FINANCIAL. TO BE COMPLIANT WITH
THOSE REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIR ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE A SEVEN WE HAVE ONE MORE
WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY NINE TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND CONNOR IS NOT MY NAME
IS ALEXANDRIA. AND I'M
REPRESENTING LEADING AGE I'M
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENT. WILLIAM AND MENTOR
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE
WILL REMAIN OPPOSED THE MONTH
AMENDED- BECAUSE WE LIKE TO
ALLOW- YES THE OPTION OF
EVACUATING THE FACILITY. IN
ADDITION- WE ARE WE NEED THE
COURT. BUILDING I THINK YOU
HAVE TO COME WITH THE MEASURE
WE ARE. GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF COMMITTEE STOCK
REPUBLICAN STAFF AND ALL THE
AUTHORS ARE AUTHORS STOP ON
FINDING A SOLUTION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH. THE
STAFF ON THE ABOUT. THANK YOU I
ASSUME THAT'S THE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANY OTHER THAT PEOPLE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION. NOT
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- SO WE'LL MOVED. MEMBER
QUESTION THE COMMENT I DO WANT
TO JUST TO ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
REMARKS GIVEN BY THE SENSITIVE-
SO OF HEALTH FACILITIES- SO
LATE YESTERDAY AFTERNOON THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
REACHED OUT TO MY STAFF TO LET
US KNOW THAT AFTER FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH FEDERAL CMS
AUTHORITIES THE INFORMATION IT
PRE RELEASE PROVIDED US OR
COMMITTEE STAFF. IN REGARD TO
THE NINETY SIX HOUR EMERGENCY
POWER REQUIREMENT MAY BE
INACCURATE SO WE DID WORK OUT
THESE AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR TAKING THEM- BUT WE
WANT TO BE SURE WE'RE- MY STAFF
IS STILL SEEKING FURTHER
EXPLAINED. AND I KNOW THAT
SHOULD THE BILL PASSED DATE
AUTHOR STAFF CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OLDER DEPARTMENT ANY
CLARIFICATION FROM CMS. AND
CLARIFYING THE BILL OF THE
PRISON NECESSARY SO I THINK WE
HAD COME TO. CENTRALLY SOME
KIND OF AGREEMENT AND BECAUSE
OF THIS UNCERTAINTY I KNOW THE
COPS COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AND CERTAINLY
WE'RE WORKING TO ADEQUATE.
CLARIFICATION CAN. ALL ISSUES
US OUT THERE FURTHER CUT
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SEE DONE CENTERED
JACK DELIGHTED THAT SITS ALWAYS
YOUR EFFORTS TO YOUR BILL AT TO
RANK FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR WHO
AREN'T SO WITH THE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I WOULD AND I
APPRECIATE. THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU. PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THERE IS
CONFUSION ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THERE ARE REGULATIONS THAT
REQUIRED THAT THEY HAVE A
NINETY SIX. HOURS OF POWER.
THAT HAVE BEEN ENFORCED AND
THEN THERE IS- AS AS WAS
POINTED OUT. LAST EVENING IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH CMS IN THE
FEDERALS FEDERAL REGULATORY
AGENCIES. SOME CONFUSION THERE
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO IS RESOLVED THAT
CONFUSION PROTECT OUR SENIORS
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
ADEQUATE POWER FOR THEM DURING
THESE VARIOUS CRISES AND TRY TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE THEIR
LIVES EASIER. AND SAFER WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR
JACKSON IS A MOTION ON THIS
BILL OKAY IT'S BEEN ALL RIGHT.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS IT'S-BEEN MOVED BY CENTER LEYVA.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI AND I NIELSEN. GONZALEZ
I. YOU MIGHT. CENTER GONZALEZ
THE BUSH MICRON HI THANKS
GONZALEZ I GROW. FOR TARA I FOR
TITLE I LEYVA. BY LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL HI MY MONEY IN MY
MONEY I RUBIO HI RUBIO HI.
SEVEN THE VOTE THAT THIS IS A
BILL CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN VOTE
SO HOLD THE ROLE OPENED FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OUR NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO- SO
SIR NIELSEN IF YOU WHEN MY
TAKING ON THE CHAIR I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO DO SOME TIME
CHECKING THAT'S ASSIST YOU IN
THAT REGARD PLEASE PROCEED
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR
SO SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO REQUIRES
A STATE CONTRACTOR PARTNER TO
MANUFACTURE INSULIN AND TEN
OTHER GENERIC DRUGS WITH THE
INTENT TO THESE DRUGS BE MADE
WIDELY AVAILABLE TO THE TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PURCHASERS
PROVIDERS AND PHARMACIES THIS
POLICY IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER AS THE COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS IS BROUGHT TO LIKE
CLEARING GAPS AND SUPPLIES
ESSENTIAL DRUGS MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES.
BASICALLY WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A RELIABLE SUPPLY
OF DRUGS NOT ONLY- IT DURING A
CRISIS BUT EVEN ON ORDINARY
TIMES- THERE HAVE BEEN
SHORTAGES OF VARIOUS GENERIC
DRUGS HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS OF
PRICING OF GENERIC DRUGS THIS
IS AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS-
WE'RE WE WOULD NOT BE THE ONLY
STATE TO ACTUALLY ENGAGE AND
EITHER DRUG AND DRUG
MANUFACTURING IS POINT OUT THE
ANALYSIS- YOU SHOULD HAVE A
MOCK UP OF THE AMENDMENTS. AND
THAT MAKING SIMPLIFYING CHANGE
THIS AND- SEKALI ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES AND I DO HAVE A TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
LINE SIR FLOCKS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
YASMIN APPELLATE FROM
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA THANK.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN. WE WOULD
NEVER PROCEED TO THE A
MODERATOR FOR ANY. TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ON WHAT SORRY GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
YES BEING POLITE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION WE ARE HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO TO CREATE THE
OFFICE OF DRUG CONTRACTING AND
MANUFACTURING CONSUMERS STILL
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS AND AFFORD
THEIR NEEDED MEDICATION ACROSS
ALL SEGMENTS OF PHARMACEUTICALS
BRAND NAME AND GENERIC AND
SPECIALTY WE SEE PRICES RISING
AROUND 90% OF ALL PRESCRIPTIONS
ARE GENERIC AND 40% OF ALL
GENERIC MEDICINES ARE MADE BY A
SINGLE MANUFACTURE. ALLOWING
THAT MANUFACTURE TO TAKE PRICES
WITHOUT COMPETITION THIS
CONSOLIDATION ULTIMATELY BE IN
THE CONSUMER PAY MORE FOR
GENERIC MEDICATION BUT THEY
SHUT IN SOME CASES A SINGLE
MANY FACTOR HAS GONE UP THE
PRICE OF LONG DEAD YOU GENERIC.
DRUG BY ASTONISHING ABOUT.
INSULIN AND ANOTHER OF PRICE
HIKES BUT LIMIT CONSUMER ACCESS
TO THE- DRUGS. BY CREATING THIS
OFFICE THE STATE COULD PROVIDE
RELIEF TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING WITH
THE HIGH COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. AND CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMPETITION IN
THE MANUFACTURING OF GENERIC
DRUGS. IN ADDITION TO SAVING
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS THE OFFICE
HAS THE CAPACITY TO SAVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THANK YOU AND YOUR RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. BUT TODAY.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION. AND
SUPPORT IT IS FOUR CHAIR
MEMBERS SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- FOR WORKERS WITH
EMPLOYER SPONSORED INSURANCE
19% OF OUR PREMIUM DOLLAR IS
SPENT ON PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
THAT'S THE REASON THAT OUR
LABOR MANAGEMENT TRUST FUNDS
HAVE PUSHED OVER THE DECADES TO
GET OUR MEMBERS ON TO GENERICS
SO WE COULD SAVE MONEY AND HAVE
MORE MONEY GO INTO WAGES AND TO
CREATING JOBS. BUT IN RECENT
YEARS WE'VE SEEN GENERICS THE
PRICE OF GENERIC SKYROCKET OR
THEIR UNAVAILABLE ACCORDING TO
SB SEVENTEEN DATA GENERIC DRUGS
HAVE THE LARGEST THREE YEAR
MEDIAN INCREASE OF ANY OTHER
TYPE OF DRUGS OVER THE RECENT
TIME PERIOD AND THAT WAS THIRTY
SEVEN POINT 6% WE KNOW THAT
PARTLY DUE TO A LACK OF
COMPETITION THAT LET COMPANY.
ONLY DROVE RIGHT BUT ALSO BEAT
YOU SHORTAGE AND PROBLEMS IN
THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN FOR THIS
REASON WE THINK CALIFORNIA IS
QUICKLY SITUATED TO FORM THIS
OFFICE IT IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY WE HAVE BY A MEDICAL
HIGH I'M TO MAKE. AND WE HAVE A
HUGE. BASED SO WE THINK THIS IS
A SMART ANTI. AND WE URGE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TO ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT ON JUDITH
SPEAK. ELECTION WHICH STARTED
THIS ROOM IN THE- NOTHING MORE
IN Q. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE HERE AND TWENTY HEARD
FORTY FOUR POINT FORTY SIX
TWENTY THREE- THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
MODERATOR IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE. ANYONE HERE IN
THE BILL THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
HEARING NONE THEN WE WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE BILL WE SEE
ONE. CENTER HER TITLE. WITH THE
BILL MOVES WILL. ANYTHING MOR
FROM MANAGERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS CHAIRMAN ONE OF THE
CLOSING STATEMENT THANK YOU SIR
NIELSEN ACTUALLY MAY WE JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT THE MODERATORS
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE EITHER
SPEAKING IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
MODERATOR. THERE ARE A FEW
ACRES I MIGHT HAVE BEEN MUTED
ON ON THAT AND- WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TWO TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS HELLO I'M EVEN
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
THAT'S ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THREE DARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A ALSO IMPORT.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO THAT'S TWO EIGHT TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE TO A TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEARING
AUDIO WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
TWO THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN THE TWO ONE NO WAY WITH
WESTERNS AND ON POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FOR THAT. UNDER. HELLO AND J.
D. AS IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SCA
YOU CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A IN
OPPOSITION GREEN THEN YOU
MODERATOR. SINCE YOU LIKE TO
VOICE OPPOSITION PRESS PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE ONE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
THAT'S TWO EIGHT TWO. PLEASE
PROCEED NOT SURE IT MIGHT
COMING THROUGH ON THAT SIR YES
YES. OKAY SORRY SIR- MY NAME IS
BRETT MICHELIN WITH THE
ASSOCIATION FOR EXCEPTIONAL
MEDICINES AND WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION AT ALL
OF THIS BILL IN FACT WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO OTHERS
SENATOR PAN- VOICING JUST
SIMPLY SOME QUESTIONS. DOES
SOME OF THE COMPONENTS OF SAID
THAT GENERICS. MEDICATIONS ARE
WHAT. REALLY REDUCE THE COST OF
MEDICATIONS FOR THE STATE AND
FOR PATIENTS HOWEVER SOME OF
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS.
PRESENTED I DO WANT TO CORRECT
THE RECORD A LITTLE BIT. SB
SEVENTEEN REPORTS SHOW THAT THE
TWENTY FIVE MOST FREQUENTLY
PRESCRIBED GENERIC DRUGS I
CALVET 39% ARE NEARLY 40% OF
ALL PRESCRIPTIONS BUT YET ARE
ONLY FOUR POINT 8% OF TOTAL
ACTUAL SPENDING. AND ONLY 3% OF
TOTAL HEALTH PLAN PREMIUMS. THE
TWENTY FIVE MOST COSTLY GENERIC
DRUGS ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY 25% OF
ALL PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND LESS
THAN 80% OF TOTAL PLANNED OUR
TOLL SPENDING ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THIS IS LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT. OF ALL HEALTH PREMIUMS.
IT'S TRUE OR THE AND FOR THE
HIGH CALL OF PRE DRUG AND- THE
CONCERN WITH THE BILL IN THE
QUESTIONS WE WANTED TO POST TO
SENATOR PAN AS SHE MOVES
FORWARD THIS TO DON'T DISRUPT
THE COMPETITION. THE STATE IS
GOING TO ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
WITH THE MANUFACTURER THAT'S
GREAT MORE OPEN TO THAT. IF
IT'S A DEFEAT- YOU KNOW- EFFORT
TO BE ABLE TO- YOU SEE STROKES
FOR THE STATE OR IF THE STATE
WANTS TO GET INTO MANUFACTURING
IT ON ITS OWN DOWN THE LINE
USER PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE
INVALID DEVELOP WAYS. BUT WHEN
YOU DO GET INVOLVED THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE CONSIDERED- AND I THINK
OUR LETTER- REALLY RACES SOME
OF THOSE WHAT WAS SENATOR PAN
AND CERTAINLY HOPE HE CONSIDERS
THOSE AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THAT
EXHAUST THE- ONLINE TESTIMONY
MODERATOR THAT IS AFFIRMATIVE
SIR ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. CLOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU AS VICE
CHAIR- AGAIN APPRECIATE- THE
COMMENTS- LET ME KNOW THAT THIS
BILL IS- PRIMARILY FOR AT THIS
STAGE TO ACTUALLY EXAMINE ALL
THE VARIOUS ISSUES SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTS- THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW. THAT TO OFFICE TO- TO
TAKING CONSIDERATION WOULD I
DON'T IMAGINE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS LOOKING TO THE
CONTRACTOR MANUFACTURE ALL
GENERICS- I THINK THE IDEA IS
TO FOCUS ON THE ONES SO WHERE
WE MIGHT. CHALLENGES ¢H
RELIABLE SUPPLY BECAUSE THERE'S
ONLY ONE MAKE SURE WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN PERHAPS THE GENERIC DRUG
MADE. PRICE SOME THAT WE- STILL
STRONG SUPPORT I AND ADEQUATE
TO. AT THE SAME TIME WE- DO
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THERE IS
SUFFICIENT- COMPETITION IN
PLACE OF FORD- PARTICULAR
GENERIC DRUGS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN GET THE BEST POSSIBLE
PRICE. SO WE WANT TO LOOK AT
ALL THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES AND
WITH THAT ASPECT WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO.
DO YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SO
I ACTUALLY JUST TO CLARIFY TO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU
SORRY I HAVE. PAN I AM HI
NIELSEN. NO NO WELCOME NIELSEN
NO GONZALEZ HI. THANK GONZALEZ
AYE AYE GROVE HER TITLE. THE
TITLE AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE ANY MONEY AYE RUBIO
AYE AYE RUBIO AYE. SEVEN ONE
SIX EIGHT IS THAT CORRECT
NUMBER. SEVEN ONE SEVEN ONE
SEVEN ONE. OKAY HOLD ON CALL
MOVES ON THE COMMITTEE. I THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN- LET'S NEXT
MOVES TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT OH THREE BY
CENTER BELL ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS WITH AMENDMENTS SB TEN
TWENTY NINE BY HAND. WITH
AMENDMENTS AND I AND NUMBER TEN
AT THE TWELVE EIGHT FIVE BY
NIELSEN CENTER NIELSEN. A MOVE
THAT ARE TO NEW BY CENTER
MINING SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. PAN HI AND I NIELSEN
AYE NIELSEN AYE GONZALEZ HI.
AND SALAS I GROW. HER TADO PINE
MEADOW AYE LEYVA. THE I AYE
MITCHELL AYE AYE MONEY IN.
MARLENE BY RUBIO HI RUBIO BY A
WE'LL PUT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER.
RIGHT SO WE CAN ASK IF CENTER
GROVE IS A PLANE TO RETURN TO
THE HEARING ROOM FOR A FOR OUR
HEARTS STOP TO FINISH
COMPLETING. CASTING HER VOTES.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO WELL WE'RE
WAITING HERE TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND WE LEARNED FOOT UNFORTUNATE
IT HAD PUT A CAP ON THEIR TIME
FOR OUR FIRST BILL CIRCLES BILL
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE VISITED
OUR WEBSITE SO THAT PLACE ANY
BILL THAT WE HEARD TODAY.
COMMON AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT INCLUDE
YOURTESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU ANY
PROCEED PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION PARTICULARLY THANK
THE STAFF I KNOW THIS IS A
CHALLENGING TIME TERMS OF
TRYING TO ORGANIZE THESE THINGS
AND I KNOW YOU'VE DONE A YEAR
AND JOB REALLY JOB AND TRYING
TO KEEP THINGS MOVING- SO- A
SEASON GROW HERE SO LET'S CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS- SO.
AND THANK EVERYONE SEE YOU OKAY
I THINK UP THREE BILLS THE FOR.
YEAH I AM NOT AGAINST VOTE ON
SO LET'S MOVE ON A GENDER. NO
THAT SB TWELVE US. BY JACKSON.
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS AMENDED
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
HI HI. OKAY AND- YOU'RE RIGHT
OKAY SO THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT
ZERO. THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
BY HAND- SECURITIES CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH.
NO GROWTH KNOWN A- TWO. FIVE
SIX THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN TWO
AND FINALLY WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AS A THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS. BRO
HI GROW BY OKAY SENT CALENDAR
IS OUT- NINE ZERO THANK YOU
THIS CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING WE ARE ADJOURNED.